le ministre de l'intérieur donc je ne
vais pas nous allons donc la séance est
ouverte mais je ne vais pas procéder à
l'appel
l'appel se fera par constat des
connexions des uns et des autres à notre
visioconférence
mes chers collègues monsieur le ministre
de l'intérieur nous vous remercions
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation pour
cette troisième audition de la mission
d'information
monsieur le ministre vous avez notamment
la charge en plus de vos missions
habituelles de maintien de l'ordre de
garantir le respect du confinement de la
population pour la protection de la
santé de tous
ce confinement tout à fait inédit fait
partie de l'arsenal des mesures
exceptionnelles prises en application de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire qui ont été
permises par la loi du 23 mars 2020 un
régime spécifique encadrent ces
restrictions temporaires apporter aux
libertés fondamentales et la loi en
parallèle a prévu que les assemblées
soit informé sans délai des mesures
prises sur le terrain par le
gouvernement elle permet également aux
assemblées de requérir toute information
complémentaire dans le cadre du contrôle
et de l'évaluation de ces mesures se
contrôler directement inspiré de celui
que vous connaissez bien monsieur le
ministre et qui a été prévu pour assurer
un suivi de l'état d'urgence décrété au
lendemain des attentats de paris
c'est la raison de notre réunion
aujourd'hui
l'adéquation des mesures mises en oeuvre
par rapport aux objectifs poursuivis
nécessite une attention particulière la
conciliation des libertés et des
nécessités de l'ordre public est
impérative
y compris dans les circonstances
exceptionnelles de la crise sanitaire
d'une ampleur inédite que nous
traversons l'organisation et les effets
du contrôle du confinement les réactions
à ces contrôles les sanctions qui ont
été entièrement prises la question des
couvre feux qui ont été pris dans
certaines huiles ou dans certains
territoires
la protection des agents qui lui mène
les exigences du maintien de l'ordre les
perspectives et les questions posées par
le tracking et l'utilisation de données
personnelles sur lequel vous vous êtes
personnellement exprimé
autant de questions que mes collègues et
moi même souhaitons aborder avec vous
ces travaux se déroule en coordination
avec des travaux menés par les
commissions chacune dans leur champ de
compétences et en particulier en
l'espèce la commission des lois
monsieur le ministre je vais vous
laisser la parole pour une intervention
liminaire synthétique afin qu'un maximum
de nos collègues puissent se soulever
devant vous les questions qui les
préoccupent les que nous puissions avoir
un véritable temps des changes les
conditions de la tenue de cette réunion
nous oblige à suivre une certaine
organisation pour qu'elle se déroule
dans de bonnes conditions
je demanderai donc à chacun comme pour
les auditions précédentes de se limiter
à une expression de deux minutes pour
formuler sa question
et mieux encore il serait utile que
chaque question n'en comporte pas
plusieurs faute de quoi ensuite
les réponses risque de prendre beaucoup
de temps
ce qui ne satisfait pas les intervenants
qui se succèdent ensuite je vous propose
que comme pour l'audition de madame
bello beyer nous commencions par une
question de la présidente de la
commission des lois ensuite nous
prendrons plusieurs séries de questions
des groupes qui donneront lieu à une
réponse groupe et dans l'ordre identique
à celui que nous avons retenue et nous
prendrons les questions quatre par
quatre et nous vous demanderons alors
monsieur le ministre d'y répondre
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés quelques mots
d'abord avant de répondre à vos
questions et vous avez eu la gentillesse
de me remercier de venir mais évidemment
je sais que c'est un usage au delà du
caractère amical de vos remerciements
c'est un usage de politesse parce que il
est normal que le ministre de
l'intérieur viennent devant vous la
représentation nationale le parlement et
l'assemblée nationale en particulier au
moment présent pour rendre compte
répondre à toutes les questions sur
lesquelles vous pouvez être amené à nous
solliciter
j'ai l'habitude de venir dans cette
salle sous la présidence de yann banque
privée dans un schéma évidemment
différent aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que
nous vivons une période particulièrement
grave
nous affrontons un ennemi le qu'ovide 19
un ennemi qui peut tous nous toucher qui
met à l'épreuve notre système de santé
un ami qui nous met à l'épreuve aussi
dans notre cohésion nationale et qui
nous interroge sur un certain nombre de
valeurs fondamentales comme celle de la
liberté le confinement est une atteinte
à la liberté nous le savons sur laquelle
il nous faut évidemment rendre compte et
c'est parfaitement logique et légitime
que vous m'interrogez ainsi depuis le
début de cette épidémie
le gouvernement a agi en prenant des
décisions fortes guidés par l'avis des
médecins par l'avis des experts des
décisions qui n'ont toujours eu qu'un
seul objectif préserver la santé des
français préserver notre système de
soins nous devions donc tout faire pour
limiter au maximum la propagation du
virus
et c'est le sens des gestes barrières
c'est le sens de la distanciation social
c'est le sens évidemment de la décision
de confinement prise par le président de
la république le 16 mars est entrée en
vigueur le 17 mars
car chacun le sait je veux le redire
quand même profiter de cette audition
chacun le sait notre meilleure arme
contre le virus c'est le confinement et
le respect du confinement et en tant que
ministre de l'intérieur
mon rôle est clair l'une de mes
priorités est clair c'est le faire
respecter
c'est la mission qui me revient avec
laurent nunez à mes côtés c'est celle à
laquelle tout le ministère s'engage
aujourd'hui pour le faire respecter nous
le devons à la fois aux français nous le
devons à leur sécurité sanitaire nous le
devons à tous les soignants qui
accomplissent un travail exceptionnel
tous les jours et je sais combien les
parlementaires sont à leurs côtés pour
les accompagner tous au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur nous avons une
mission face à la crise je pense que si
vous permettez une super jeu présenté un
peu le dispositif dans lequel nous
travaillons je pense d'abord au préfet
et au corps préfectoral point de repère
en période de crise et qui depuis
plusieurs semaines sont à la manoeuvre
côté des agences régionales de santé
je pense aux personnels de préfecture
qui sont totalement mobilisés alors que
je pense aux sapeurs pompiers à toute la
communauté de la sécurité civile qui est
déterminante pour aider notre système de
soins je pense à ceux qui à beauvau font
fonctionner chaque jour la cellule d'un
terminal de crise ainsi qu à tous ceux
qui ont été mobilisés pour élaborer les
lois les ordonnances et les décrets
nécessaires pour faire face à la
situation épidémique
je pense enfin à nos policiers et à nos
gendarmes qui arpentent les rues
interviennent les contrôles partout sans
aucune exception pour faire respecter
les mesures prises pour faire face à
l'épidémie
avec pédagogie avec discernement
leur mission est exigeante et nous
devons faire bloc avec eux
leur mission est exigeante en plus que
leur travail ne se limite pas à ces
tâches exceptionnel et nouvelles qui
résultent de l'épidémie du cobp et 19
leurs activités en effet ne s'arrête pas
sur les fronts de la lutte contre la
délinquance ou contre le terrorisme et
le drame que nous avons vécu à
romans-sur-isère nous le rappelle
mais avant d'aller plus loin je vais
avant de répondre à vos questions je
souhaitais en quelques mots bref faire
un premier bilan avec vous de la période
que nous connaissons actuellement
d'abord je souhaite revenir de manière
sur la manière dont est construite la
réponse de l'état face à l'urgence
sanitaire coordonnait ferme
cette réponse suit les orientations
fixées par le présent de la république
en particulier dans les conseils de
défense et de sécurité nationale et à la
lumière des recommandations du conseil
scientifique placée auprès du chef de
l'état sous l'autorité unique du premier
ministre cette réponse repose sur trois
piliers
tout d'abord le centre de crise
sanitaire du ministère des solidarités
de la santé qui en charge la réponse
sanitaire à la crise ensuite le centre
de crise des ministères du ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères qui
est chargée notamment de la gestion des
français qui sont à l'étranger qui
souhaitent revenir sur le territoire
national et enfin il ya au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur
la cellule interministérielle de crise
la cic7 cellule fonctionne et n'existent
qu'au service des décisions prises par
le premier ministre c'est pourquoi elle
rassemble en son sein dans ces
différentes réunions quotidiennes tu
pourrais les évoquer si vous souhaitez
tous les ministères qui sont concernés
par la crise lé préfet quant à eux sont
dans chaque département en charge de
coordonner notre action et j'assure pour
mac
en lien avec eux tous les soirs une
réunion depuis l'installation du 17 mars
où je les informe non seulement des
décisions prises en tentant de les
expliquer mais je vais aux saillies à
recueillir leurs observations
elles permettent ces réunions de mieux
appréhender les problèmes qui se posent
sur le territoire cette démarche c'est
l'assurance que les mesures que nous
prenons sont applicables qu'elles sont
appliquées et si nécessaire corriger
parce que nous devons tenir compte des
circonstances propres au plus près de
nos concitoyens je vais aussi profité de
cet instant pour souligner l'engagement
remarquable des préfets et de toutes et
tous ceux qui travaillaient à la cic ou
en préfecture côté des préfets qui
n'économisent pas leurs efforts je vais
vous préciser que aujourd'hui ce sont 72
agents qui arme
la cic 72 agents issus de dix ministères
la cic est organisé en différentes
cellules suivant leurs munitions
classiques de la cellule de crise
situation anticipation logistique
communication et décision est par
ailleurs en plus de ces cellules
habituel une cellule dite thématique
interministérielle a été créé dès la
première semaine de confinement pour au
fond trancher les questions complexes
qui touche plusieurs ministères et faire
en sorte que là aussi on se remonte dans
le l'interministérialité de la cic qui
je le rappelle est placé sous l'autorité
du premier ministre
le système a fait ses preuves vous avez
évoqué des précédents moment
exceptionnel les attentes à 2015 jouer
ou qui les intempéries violentes qui
avaient affecté saint martin et saint
barthélémy il permet cette coordination
efficace des services de l'état une
réponse rapide aux enjeux que nous
rencontrons je veux ajouter que la cic
dépôt un certain nombre d'outils pour
nous permettre de mieux aborder la crise
sanitaire
une plateforme pour les acteurs
étatiques de cette crise a été créée et
par ailleurs monsieur le président je
garde la plus grande attention à ce que
le contrôle parlementaire de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire soit opérée dans de
bonnes conditions
c'est ainsi que pour le compte du
premier ministre une plateforme vient
d'être mise en place pour vous permettre
d'accéder à l'ensemble des arrêtés
préfectoraux sur le fondement de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
avec une mise à jour hebdomadaire pour
que vous puissiez justement faire le
contrôle est sollicité de notre part
tous les éléments nécessaires à ce
contrôle voilà pour l'organisation de la
cic je reviens maintenant à la manière
dont le ministère s'emploie sur le
terrain à faire respecter le confinement
des consignes ont été passées et répété
aux français autour d'un mot d'ordre
clair
restez chez vous
quelques exceptions strictes ont été
prévus pour cette règle et expliquer aux
français
chaque personne qui souhaite sortir ne
peut le faire qu'avec parcimonie et avec
son attestation dûment rempli pour faire
respecter cette règle nous avons déployé
en moyenne cent mille policiers et
gendarmes partout sur le territoire pour
qu'ils puissent contrôler et faire
respecter le confinement nos forces de
l'ordre mènent une action remarquable
les chiffres de maths ce matin ce sont 9
5 millions de contrôles depuis le début
du confinement et plus de 560 8000
verbalisation nous avons aussi montré
notre capacité à nous développer et à
nous projeter sur le terrain sur des
moments particuliers au monde
d'appréhension de risque de population
de mouvements de population au début des
vacances scolaires de la zone c nous
avions une inquiétude qui a été partagé
par beaucoup y compris de ceux qui nous
écoutent sur les mouvements vers des
lieux de vacances ou de villégiature
nous avons déployé depuis vendredi matin
cent soixante mille policiers et
gendarmes qui ont procédé à des
contrôles renforcés et on peut dire que
très globalement mais au delà même du
globalement dans la quasi atteinte de la
totalité de nos objectifs cette règle a
été respectée peu de français sont
partis pour prendre des vacances et nous
sommes intervenus à la fois au moment du
départ à la fois sur les trajets à la
fois sur les sites d'arrivée j'y
reviendrai si vous êtes des questions
sur cela évidemment je n'évoque pas les
sanctions vous les connaissez vous les
avez voté il y a quelques jours et vous
savez l'importance qu'elles peuvent
avoir aussi mais je veux m'en vont
insister sur le fait que les contrôles
se déploient partout sans aucune
exception
ainsi des quartiers huppés aux banlieues
des quartiers pavillonnaires aux zones
rurales l'intégralité de la france
depuis le début du confinement a fait
l'objet de contrôles et je le dis parce
que je sais qu'il est certainement
beaucoup plus difficile de respecter le
confinement quand on vit à plusieurs
dans un appartement dans une tour dans
un quartier bétonné que quand on vit
dans un pavillon avec un jardin dans une
charmante commune des
alpes-de-haute-provence où dans le
morbihan mais ce que je sais c'est que
nous devons veiller à ce que partout
nous respections ce qu'induit l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
vous le savez l'état d'urgence sanitaire
à habiliter essentiellement le premier
ministre le ministre chargé de la santé
au plan et au plan local les préfets à
prendre des mesures utiles pour faire
face à cela et c'est évidemment dans ce
cadre là que nous intervenons pour
conclure je sais que vocation porteront
sur la protection des personnels qui
continue aujourd'hui d'exercer en
particulier et en particulier celle des
forces de l'ordre je ne suis pas médecin
je ne suis pas une autorité scientifique
dès lors notre action dans ce domaine a
correspondu à la stricte mise en oeuvre
des doctrines arrêté par les autorités
sanitaires j'y reviendrai si vous le
souhaitez d'ailleurs c'est un principe
que j'applique et que le gouvernement
applique depuis le début et je
continuerai à le faire mais nous
pourrons évidemment le détail et je ne
veux pas en effet être trop longue mais
je voudrais vraiment je voulais vraiment
évoquer ces schémas d'organisation que
sont les schémas d'organisation
exceptionnel auquel évidemment nous ne
sommes pas habitués et joel salué
l'engagement transversale et
interministériels de l'ensemble des
membres du gouvernement de l'ensemble de
nos administrations du national
évidemment jusqu'au local pour faire en
sorte que le combat que nous menons pour
penser qu'il sera un combat long et
difficile puisse permettre de préserver
au maximum la sécurité au sens le plus
large possible de nos concitoyens
merci monsieur le ministre il me revient
de poser les premières questions
le confinement inédit de la population
française est le pilier de notre combat
contre l'épidémie
son respect est primordial vous avez
rappelé les français en ont
collectivement pris conscience le
confinement le sait commencera à porter
ses fruits mais ces résultats ne seront
sensibles que si nous maintenons cet
effort
le périmètre exact des dérogations au
confinement a parfois suscité des
questions chez nos concitoyens
je pense notamment aux marchés et
quelles instructions ont été données aux
forces de l'ordre dans l'application de
ces règles
mon deuxième point concerne les
forces de sécurité intérieure dont je
tiens à saluer l'engagement sur le
terrain pour assurer le respect des
mesures de confinement mais permettez
moi d'ailleurs de saisir l'occasion pour
dire que j'en ai la certitude l'ensemble
des parlementaires des députés qui
participent à cette mission dont qui n'y
participent pas mesure l'engagement de
tous les fonctionnaires placés sous
votre autorité qu'il soit dans les
préfectures qu'ils soient sur le terrain
comme policier ou gendarme ou qu'il soit
pompier ou partout ailleurs dans
l'action publique et je me permet
d'exprimer donc notre profonde
reconnaissance à l'ensemble de ses
équipes
alors c'est une mission difficile pour
laquelle que de tenir
l'application de ce confinement pour
laquelle les forces de sécurité
intérieure ne se considère pas
suffisamment équipés lorsque l'on lit un
certain nombre de déclarations et
notamment en particulier s'agissant des
masques de protection pouvez-vous sur le
ministre nous indiquer quelle est la
doctrine d'équipement appliquée par
votre ministère autres administrations
cette doctrine est elle susceptible
d'évoluer les dotations en équipements
sont elles à la hauteur des besoins pour
aujourd'hui pour les semaines qui
viennent et puis par ailleurs je crois
que c'est une question que beaucoup se
posent c'est quelle mesure
envisagez-vous pour la reconnaissance
professionnelle des policiers et des
gendarmes qui dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions auraient contracté le corona
virus voilà pour introduire nos échanges
les deux premières questions que je
voulais vous poser avant de céder
ensuite la parole à la présidente de la
commission des lois
adam et ève routhier merci monsieur le
président vous avez évoqué le cadre du
confinement et la proche qui en est
faite par les différents acteurs du
ministère de l'intérieur des préfets par
exemple sur les marchés j'y reviendrai
aux forces de sécurité intérieure quand
ils procèdent au contrôle des
attestations et du respect du
confinement
la règle c'est le discernement c'est
d'autant plus nécessaire que la mise en
place des moyens de contrôle s'est fait
au moins de 24 heures et que en moins de
24 heures nos forces de sécurité
intérieure ont été présentes partout
pour faire en sorte que le confinement
parce que nous savions qu'il était
essentiel que les français comprennent
ce que cela impliquait soit massivement
respecter ils l'ont été
la consigne c'est celle du discernement
le discernement c'est un exercice plus
difficile que d'autres parce qu' il est
plus facile d'appliquer une règle simple
écrites sur lequel il suffit de cocher
des cases mais c'est parce que nous
attendons de nos policiers et nos
gendarmes
et donc si les règles sont posées de
façon stricte restez chez vous on ne
sort pas il est prévu évidemment que le
transport pendulaires domicile-travail
puisse être autorisée nous avons mis en
place une attestation qui a évolué
ensuite pas être simplifiées encore pour
ce sujet là et puis nous avons mis en
place aussi des dérogations qui
permettent par exemple de se rendre chez
le médecin ou qui permettent par exemple
d'aller faire ses courses et nous avons
invité nos forces de sécurité à
appliquer cela dans le respect des
libertés fondamentales de chacun et donc
dans le respect aussi du droit le droit
dont vous êtes les garants dans son
édition et dont je suis le garant dans
son application
et donc il était essentiel aussi que
nous construisions cela dans un rapport
de confiance sur l'ensemble des
verbalisations qui est ont eu lieu
j'ai eu très peu de retours d'anomalie
grave très peu souvent elles ont été
allégué elles sont sorties sur les
réseaux sociaux et quand nous les avons
vérifié elle n'était pas confirmée il
n'empêche que l'exercice a pu amener à
quelques erreurs d'interprétation le
fait de fouiller un sac de courses par
exemple ne correspond pas à la bonne
application de la doctrine que nous
l'avons fixé et donc je dirais
chaque jour chaque heure sous l'autorité
du dgpn tu dggn et du préfet de police
la doctrine de gestion a été appliquée
toujours avec ce seul souci celui du
discernement et de l'intelligence dans
le contact mais ce que je sais c'est que
globalement il y a eu assez peu
d'incidents qui nous seront montées
assez peu de saisie de la plate forme de
l'igpn par exemple qui est un indicateur
qui nous permet de voir et puis nous
avons aussi veiller à ce que les délais
de recours contre les contraventions
soit porté de 45 à 90 jours parce qu'il
est aussi parfaitement légitime que les
recours contre une contravention
puissent être examinés sur les marchés
là aussi nous partons d'une règle simple
le premier annoncé un décret a été
étiqueté les marchés sont interdits mais
nous savions l'importance aussi des
marchés à la fois l'importance sociale
on peut faire ses courses moins cher sur
certains marchés que dans l'épicerie du
coin et on sait combien c'est important
pour certains de nos concitoyens à la
fois en termes d'approvisionnement parce
que quelquefois le petit marché est le
seul approvisionnement possible en
matière d'alimentation de la commune du
village dans lequel on vit il n'est pas
utile d'être obligé de prendre sa
voiture pour aller dans le bourg centre
et puis à la fois en termes de
d'activités agricoles et de vente
directe nous aurons beaucoup de marché
où les ventes directes sont l'essentiel
de l'organisation agricole d'un
territoire
il est important de prendre seul en tête
donc nous avons fait une doctrine aussi
spécifique pour les préfets que nous
avons soumis aussi pour l'organisation
spatiale des marchés au ministère de la
santé pour faire en sorte que les gestes
barrières soient organisés au sein même
du marché et c'est dans ce cadre là que
les préfets apprécié en lien avec les
maires et c'est la consigne constante
que je donne au cas par cas la
possibilité de déroger donc de prendre
un arrêté qui autorise la réouverture du
marché alors que la règle est celle de
la fermeture
sumo interrogé sur les équipements de
protection et sur la reconnaissance
professionnelle des policiers et des
gendarmes
je voudrais vous dire que le premier axe
sur lequel nous sommes intervenus c'est
celui d'insister tout d'abord sur les
gestes barrières et les mesures de
distanciation sociale il est
indispensable à la fois que nos forces
et nos représentants les préfets aussi
l'administration territoriale de l'état
aussi le respecte cela parce que c'est
la meilleure des préventions pour eux
aussi parce qu'ils se doivent d'être
exemplaires dans leur comportement pour
montrer aussi à nos concitoyens ce qu'il
faut faire et je crois que cela a
préservés alors que le virus ne
circulait pas encore librement sur le
territoire national l'ensemble des
moyens dont nous disposions nous avons
ensuite fait évoluer évidemment cette
doctrine avec l'évolution de la
circulation du virus sur le territoire
national
j'ai ainsi veiller dès le début du mois
de mars dans le strict respect de la
doctrine gouvernementale d'utilisation
des masques telle qu'elle a été définie
et en prenant en compte le contexte
opérationnel du ministère à ce que des
kits de protection soient disponibles
dans tous les véhicules de patrouille ou
d'interventions auprès de ceux qui sont
chargés de recevoir le public dans les
commissariats les brigades de
gendarmerie ou les guichets des
préfectures
il a été précisé et c'est la doctrine
que les masques devait être portée en
cas de contact avec une personne
présentant un ou des symptômes ducobu 19
ou dans des cas de figure présentant un
risque important de cette nature cette
doctrine a été présenté au sein du chsct
exceptionnel du 9 mars par le secrétaire
général du ministère l'a d'ailleurs été
précisée par une instruction du
directeur général de la police nationale
le 13 mars et des consignes du directeur
général de la gendarmerie nationale les
16 et 27 mars
le 23 mars pour répondre aux
interrogations qui résultait de la
progression de la diffusion de ce virus
j'ai souhaité qu'une réunion se tienne
avec les organisations syndicales de la
police nationale en lien avec la
gendarmerie nationale et le directeur
général de la santé le professeur
salomon sur la dotation en équipements
les stocks disponibles d'équipements de
protection disponibles ont été réparties
jusqu'au niveau départemental en
application de cette doctrine
c'est ainsi que j'ai fait procéder à des
livraisons successives de masques pour
la police nationale et la gendarmerie
les préfectures à partir du 13 mars
distribution de huit cent dix mille
masques qu'ils étaient ici du stock
ministériel dont nous disposions les
distributions se sont échelonnés entre
le 14 et le 23 mars selon les sites
le 26 mars ce sont 300 mille masques
supplémentaires qui ont été diffusées et
répartis entre la police nationale et la
pp et la gendarmerie nationale par
ailleurs notre service ministériel des
achats et notre filière logistique ont
été mobilisés sans relâche pour acquérir
des équipements individuels de
protection
là aussi cette activité s'est fait dans
le strict cadre de la doctrine est des
règles définies au niveau national
notamment pour ce qui concerne la
possibilité de procéder à des
importations
ainsi que les 3 et 4 avril des commandes
de 2 5 millions de masques en provenance
de chine ont été réceptionnés les
livraisons sont en cours la ventilation
se fait entre un peu moins de 1 million
400 mille masques pour la police
nationale
un peu plus d'un million par jour de
l'armée nationale et 87 mille pour la
préfecture 3,6 millions de masques ont
ainsi été livrés aux services du
ministère depuis le début de la crise
dans le strict respect des règles
d'allocation de ce dispositif et dans le
cadre d'une doctrine d'usagé arrêté en
lien avec les autorités sanitaires
je suis un peu long monsieur le
président que je sais que c'est une
question qui reviendra régulièrement et
il me semble que c'est utile de la poser
ainsi pour permettre d'avoir d'autres
questions nous avions un stock de
masques de type ffp2 masque réservée au
personnel soignant et intervenants dans
les hôpitaux un stop 2,1 millions 46
mille masques qu'ils étaient un million
quatre cent soixante mille masques qui
étaient répartis un peu plus de 200
milles dans les gammes is cent mille à
l'établissement centrale logistique de
la police et un peu moins d'un million
deux cent mille dans les régions de
gendarmerie j'ai demandé que la totalité
de ces masques là sous réserve de
conserver qu'un homme un stock pour
certaines interventions spécifiques non
liés aux que vides soit remis aux ars à
partir du 26 mars
en parallèle j'ai demandé dès la mi mars
qu des prospections soit engagée pour
identifier les dispositifs de protection
alternatif et en particulier pour la
protection des yeux est aussi un vecteur
de propagation du virus et compte tenu
d'un certain nombre d'incidents graves
et notamment des personnes contrôlées
qui ont pu cracher au visage des
policiers ou des gendarmes qui le contre
l'hymne semblait nécessaire de faire
cela et donc nous avons développé là
aussi notre politique d'acquisitions
à ce jour 61 mille paires de lunettes de
protection ont été livrés 81 mille
paires de lunettes supplémentaires ont
été commandés 50 et un mille visière qui
ont été commandés en complément des
billets fabriqués localement dans les
fab lab qui sont testés dans certaines
unités 32000 max textile ont été
commandés dont vingt-deux mille sont en
cours de livraison des plaques de
plexiglas sont désormais installés dans
de nombreux sites au niveau d accueil du
public lorsqu'il en était dépourvu
d'ici le 26 avril 14 millions de masques
supplémentaires devraient être livrés
j'utilise le conditionnel parce que
chacun sait les l'incertitude que nous
avons sur le pont aérien et des
incidents que nous avons pu connaître au
total monsieur le président ce sont 40
millions de masques commandés par le
ministère de l'intérieur au moment où je
vous parle
la deuxième question sur laquelle vous
m'interrogez porte sur la reconnaissance
professionnelle des agents qui aura été
qui aurait pu qui ont contracté le virus
c'est une question particulièrement
importante au moment où je vous parle
près de 1400 fonctionnaire du ministère
de l'intérieur
tout le ministère de l'intérieur
confondues sont à ce jour reconnu
affecté par le cos vide 19 de manière
avérée il faut rapporter ça évidemment à
l'ensemble de la population du ministère
d'un ter soit près de trois cent mille
personnes et donc ça nous fait un taux
qui est inférieure à 0 50% mais c'est un
taux élevé et c'est de toute façon pour
chaque cas une personne qui a été ou qui
est en souffrance et je pense aussi aux
personnes décédées au sein d'ailleurs de
toutes les administrations de notre
ministère nous avons connu des deuils
même si ce sont les personnes qui
n'étaient pas en contact avec le public
il chose est sûre c'est que ça marqué
chacune de nos administrations et
chacune de nos directions et donc il me
paraît évident que le facteur
d'exposition accrue au risque même en
observant strictement les gestes
barrières et en bénéficiant des
matériels de protection que je viens
d'évoquer dans le cadre défini par les
autorités sanitaires est un sujet qui
doit être prise en compte
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
souhaite que le coc vide 19 soit inscrit
au tableau des maladies reconnues comme
étant professionnel et c'est pourquoi je
souhaite également que le lien de
l'affection avec le service soit présumé
pour les agents dont est établi qu'ils
ont assuré la mission au contact du
public durant la période de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
j'ai été interpellé par deux syndicats
sur ce sujet alliance et l'unsa mais je
sais que c'est une préoccupation globale
de nos forces de sécurité intérieure et
de nos personnels j'ai donc saisi
formellement le 7 avril le ministre
chargé de la fonction publique et des
maladies professionnelles
le ministre olivier vallerand et le
ministre gérald darmanin pour que cette
reconnaissance se traduisent au plus
vite
voilà monsieur le président ce que
voulez-vous précisé merci monsieur le
ministre pour ces éléments de réponse
la parole est à la présidente de la
commission des lois est rapporteur madam
michelle braun pie v est déjà prêt nous
passerons la parole aux représentants
des différents groupes ou de la parole
madame la présidente
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
déjà pour vous remercier de votre
annonce concernant le personnel qui est
particulièrement exposée aux commis 19
dans l'exercice de ses fonctions
j'espère et je compte bien que le
personnel pénitentiaire puisse
bénéficier de ce dispositif parce qu'il
est lui aussi exposés quotidiennement au
risque vous avez rappelé la doctrine de
gestion du respect du confinement
nos concitoyens ont besoin de clarté or
on voit fleurir sur le territoire
national un certain nombre d'arrêté
prévoyant des couvre-feux locaux voire
départementaux parfois interdit à aux
citoyens de s'asseoir sur un banc par
format leur interdit de s'éloigner
depuis dix mètres de leur domicile avant
les oblige à porter un masque
je voudrais que vous indiquiez quelle
est votre vision et quelle est la
doctrine du ministère de l'intérieur sur
ces différentes initiatives car l'autre
naamar problématiques parfois au
juridique qui s'opposent
moi j'ai le sentiment que parfois on
peut assister à une forme de surenchère
local qui pourrait donner à nos
concitoyens le sentiment que ils sont
plus ou moins protégés à leurs élus
selon leur endroit
l'endroit où ils habitent et j'aimerais
savoir si vous avez une doctrine que
vous pourriez donner sur le territoire
national et enfin je voulais vous
interroger sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme que taper rappeler que notre
pays avait été récemment endeuillée vous
avez indiqué également que votre
ministère est totalement mobilisée pour
faire face à la lutte contre l'épidémie
néanmoins la menace persiste je scelle
j'aimerais saluer vos services qu'ils
continuent à nous adresser les actes
pris en application de la loi de lutte
contre le terrorisme pour que nous
puissions à la commission rodez bike
voilà comment à organiser vous votre
ministère faire face à cette menace
toujours présente j'ai nommé merci
madame la présidente
la parole est à monsieur eric ciotti
pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
souhaiter bon courage dans l'exercice de
votre mission et mission difficile et au
travers vous exprimer ma reconnaissance
à tous les personnels du ministère de
l'intérieur
avec une mention particulière bien sûr
aux policiers aux gendarmes pompiers
personnels de la sécurité civile mais
également au préfet à tous leurs
collaborateurs qui incarne l'état et ses
briques on a besoin d'un état fort dans
cette période et d'un état qui est une
doctrine qui s'applique partout sur le
territoire national je voudrais monsieur
le ministre vous interrogé aujourd'hui
sur la menace sécuritaire sur la menace
terroriste qui aujourd'hui nous l'avons
vu ce week-end est malheureusement
toujours au coeur des grands enjeux
nationaux
gv aucune mesure et menaces sécuritaires
au lendemain sans doute de la crise
sanitaire
mon inquiétude est ce que demain lorsque
l'épisode pandémique aura perdu de son
ampleur nous n'ayons face à nous des
enjeux de sécurité qui se multipliaient
qui se développe j'ai des inquiétudes
les inquiétudes notamment face à la
libération massive de détenus madame b
loubet a parlé de 8000 détenue à ce jour
à ce rythme il y aura moins de vingt
mille détenus dans quelques semaines
dans notre pays
ces personnes souvent des trafiquants de
drogue seront à nouveau sur le marché de
la délinquance j'ai une inquiétude par
rapport à la menace terroriste d'autant
que madame belloubet là encore nous a
indiqué hier que d'ores et déjà 25
détenus de droit commun à radicaliser
avaient été libérés j'ai une inquiétude
par rapport à la situation de
l'immigration dans la mesure où
quasiment tous les centres de rétention
sont aujourd'hui fermées
étrangers présentant les menaces les
plus forts sont dans la nature
mais question sera simple combien
aujourd'hui d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière sont encore dans les centres
de rétention combien de sang de
rétention sont ouverts quelles mesures
avez vous prises poursuivre les détenus
radicaliser qui ont été libérés et pour
éviter que la menace terroriste qui
demeure maximale ne se concrétise à
nouveau je vous remercie monsieur me
disent merci monsieur ciotti
la parole est à madame marielle de
sarnez pour le groupe mouvement
démocrate et apparentés merci monsieur
le président dans la crise que nous
vivons la coopération et la solidarité
entre pays sont des éléments essentiels
dans le monde et chez nous en europe
cela vaut pour la question de l'épidémie
mais cela devra s'imposer tout
particulièrement aux la période de
sortie du confinement qu'en cette
période interviendra nous le savons
cette sortie ne se fera pas de façon
simultanée pour tous les états membres
par exemple l'autriche et le danemark
ont d'ores et déjà annoncé des plans
nationaux de levée progressive des
mesures de confinement
la question du contrôle sanitaire aux
frontières intérieures de l'union
européenne sera donc posée et je crois
qu'il serait vraiment préférable que les
décisions prises le soin de façon
coordonnée entre pays et non dispersés
cela vaut pour la gestion sanitaire de
nos frontières intérieures
cela vaut aussi pour la gestion
sanitaire de nos frontières extérieures
et pour les règles qui s'imposeront dès
lors aux ressortissants des pays tiers
sur ces questions il est essentiel de
disposer d'une stratégie qui soit claire
lisible compréhensible par tous et
surtout directement utiles dans la lutte
contre la pandémie
monsieur le ministre merci de nous
préciser la politique que vous entendrez
poursuivre en la matière
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur david habib
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur ministre comme mes collègues je
veux saluer l'investissement le travail
des fonctionnaires qui sont placés sous
votre autorité monsieur le ministre les
policiers les gendarmes les pompiers
toutes celles et ceux qui contribuent à
faire fonctionner nos services publics
qui le font avec incompétence et un
dévouement qui méritera oui peut-être
salut je veux bien évidemment m'incliner
aussi devant avec respect devant travail
et la bonne organisation qui est mise en
place par les préfets je le vois dans
mon département des pyrénées atlantiques
c'est fabuleux
admirable quand on constate cet
investissement on en est que plus gêné
par les déclarations du préfet de police
de paris monsieur didier lallement et je
voulais commencer mon propos en
stigmatisant ceux qui a été plus qu'une
erreur c'est une faute qui a été commise
par ce préfet de police est appelée
votre attention sur le sentiment de
culpabilité que ces propos ont pu faire
naître chez sa tante de nos concitoyens
vous avez évoqué ensuite la situation
des policiers des gendarmes qui
aujourd'hui sont malade confiné qui ont
souffert du virus vous avez essayé de
développer une argumentation autour d'un
respect de la doctrine nationale en
matière sanitaire
mais dès le 23 mars monsieur le ministre
les organisations syndicales de
policiers vous avait alerté sur la
nécessité de recourir à des masques et à
l'époque vous comme monsieur lunesse
n'avait pas entendu leur demande
et aujourd'hui vous parler de 40
millions de masques commandés
nous constatons avec une certaine
amertume que les policiers et les
gendarmes n'avaient pas été écoutés dans
le début de la période de confinement
enfin je veux évoquer le premier tour
des municipales
je veut clairement dire que le parti
socialiste n'a jamais demandé jamais
demandé le maintien de ce scrutin
il est faux de prétendre le contraire
s'il y a une responsabilité dans le
choix de maintenir ce premier tour il
faudra le chercher ailleurs que dans
notre formation puisque j'évoque le
scrutin du 15 mars
pouvez vous nous en donner des chiffres
sur le nombre d'élus et d'assesseurs
scrutateurs atteints par le virus
merci merci monsieur habib
la parole est à monsieur olivier becht
pour le groupe u10 agir et indépendant
merci monsieur le président l'ennemi
pendant écrivent
malheureusement les travaux de la
criminalité continue si je pourrais
m'exprimer ainsi
c'est vrai à la fois des violences
intrafamiliales c'est vrai également de
la criminalité qui s'organise sur les
trafics de masques de respirateurs ou
encore de test mais c'est également vrai
de ceux qui veulent frapper la france
nos ennemis traditionnels
hélas dans les mouvements terroristes et
pendant que nos policiers gendarmes sont
occupés à vérifier si nos concitoyens
vont bien au supermarché avec la bonne
attestation ou s'ils ne partent pas en
vacances pour se rendre dans une
résidence autre que la leur
malheureusement et bien il faut
également veiller aux autres moyens de
la criminalité et donc je souhaiterais
que vous puissiez vous faire un point
justement sur les moyens qui restent
mobilisés pour assurer la sécurité des
français au quotidien mais également
assurer la sécurité des infrastructures
stratégiques
les dépôts pétroliers notamment les
centrales nucléaires les réseaux de
transport voilà en ce que dans le
contexte de la crise sanitaire la france
ne doit pas baisser la garde face à ses
ennemis qui pourraient profiter
malheureusement est bien de malheur pour
nous frapper
je vous remercie merci monsieur bêche
monsieur le ministre je vous donne la
parole pour répondre à l'ensemble des
questions que les collègues viennent de
vous poser je vais tenter mathieu le
président d'être exhaustif et si jamais
j'ai oublié des éléments on peut me
signaler je fais une réponse par mail
plus précise et en tant que de besoin
d'ailleurs y compris sur mes propres
répond si cela vous paraît nécessaire
la présidente de la commission des lois
mme interrogé sur le risque qu'il y ait
effectivement l'a évoqué des surenchères
local mais qui est des approches trop
différente sur le territoire de longeaux
national de respect notamment du
confinement et ce risque existe ma
stratégie les consignes que j'ai donnée
au préfet depuis le début est de
toujours chercher à construire à
co-construire une réponse au plus près
du territoire avec les élus locaux
le meilleur exemple ça a été les
couvre-feux il ya eu des initiatives
prix sur les couvre-feux j'ai
systématiquement demandé au préfet de
voir comment encadrer juridiquement les
couvre-feux parce qu'il y avait un débat
d'ailleurs sur la compétence des maires
à prendre ce type d'arrêté
mais je n'ai posé que de règle celle du
dialogue constant entre préfet et
municipalités à travers leurs
représentants et celle du fait que s'il
devait y avoir couvre-feu je souhaitais
qu'il soit sur l'ensemble du territoire
communal et pas seulement sur tel ou tel
quartier pour éviter la stigmatisation
de telle ou tel quartier et c'est ainsi
que les choses se sont faites et il est
arrivé que je demande au préfet de
mettre de la coordination d'ensemble
dans les alpes-maritimes plusieurs
municipalités avaient pris des
initiatives certaines au milieu pouvait
représenter des trous et donc des
incohérences et donc le préfet a pris la
décision de prendre un arrêté
départemental de mise en oeuvre de
cohérence globale mais c'est vrai qu'on
voit un certain nombre d'initiatives
aujourd'hui qui peuvent apparaître soit
contestable juridiquement soit mettant
en cause les libertés fondamentales
soi-même pouvons prendre le risque et je
sais que ce n'est pas l'intention des
auteurs de au fond laisser penser qu'on
peut sortir du confinement avec des
mesures comme le port du masque
obligatoire or tel n'est pas le cas
ce que j'ai demandé notamment sur les
arrêtés qui prévoit le port du masque
obligatoire dans les communes dont nous
savons que la base juridique est plus
qu'incertaine
et j'utilise un ne fusent en vous disant
cela
j'ai demandé au préfet de prendre langue
avec l'ensemble des maires peu hier soir
il y en avait deux seulement qui a pris
deux arrêtés de ce type là pour montrer
que c'était à la fois pas cohérent par
rapport à l'exigence qu'implique le
confinement parce que ça peut laisser
penser qu' on peut sortir si on un
masque en s'affranchissant des règles du
confinement
que c'est un sujet d'égalité
territoriales parce que certaines
communes peuvent avoir les moyens
d'équiper l'ensemble de leur population
en masque quand d'autres ne l'aurait pas
et donc du coup ça pourrait même
interdire à des habitants de la commune
voisine de venir dans la commune donc
c'est quand même un sujet un peu
problématique
et puis c'est aussi un sujet qui n'est
pas médicalement démontrer vous savez
les débats qui existe sur ce sujet mais
je lui ai dit je suis pas médecin je
veux pas prononcé sur cela et donc j'ai
demandé au préfet de prendre langue avec
ses maires pour qu'ils retirent leurs
arrêtés pendant toute la période du
confinement et que nous puissions en
fonction de la doctrine nationale qui
sera mise en oeuvre pour sortir du
confinement le moment venu travailler
avec eux pour des adaptations locales si
elles apparaissent nécessaires
ce que je souhaite c'est que on puisse
renforcer au fond partout on a un signe
de relâchement
là où on est un signe de relâchement il
est important qu avec l'équipe
municipale en place nous puissions
trouver les moyens de marquer la volonté
des autorités publiques et je me mets au
même niveau ministère de l'intérieur et
collectivités locales même si je ne suis
pas dans un débat juridique en vous
disant cela pour durcir par tous est
nécessaire mais évitons effectivement
des arrêtés qui pose des principes qui
sont pour le moins contestable il faut
accepter l'idée que les gens peuvent
sortir de chez eux
aujourd'hui on est un peu tombé dans un
travers ou toute personne dehors serait
suspecte d'enfreindre la règle non il ya
des dérogations possibles et nous
pensons d'ailleurs qu'elles sont
nécessaires y compris celle de pouvoir
sortir et se dit gêné mais il faut
l'organiser et c'est le sens du travail
que nous menons ensemble sur ce sujet là
sur la lutte contre le terrorisme c'est
une question qui me permettra de votre
question à la prison de répondre aussi à
hasselt eric ciotti vous dire que
évidemment personne n'a baissé la garde
sur la prévention et sur le combat et la
lutte contre le terrorisme
ceci le sens de la question de monsieur
bêche à la fin de vos interventions
ça fait partie évidemment des sujets qui
sont des sujets prioritaires pour nous
et sur lequel nous devons être
totalement mobilisés et les services
continue à travailler
j'ai d'ailleurs demandé que nous
puissions prendre en compte le risque
majeur de sur accident que nous
pourrions connaître dans l'organisation
même des services qui sont directement
mobilisent
abl sur des sujets d'exception je pense
à la dgs si je pense à la dcpj et aux
dates
je pense aussi au raid ou au gign ou là
j'ai demandé une organisation au sein du
service avec des équipes alternée qui ne
se croisent pas de sorte que nous
puissions toujours avoir des personnels
mobilisés samedi après-midi à romans
avant que le procureur national anti
terrorisme ne prenne sa décision de
qualifier cela en lien avec le
terrorisme de prendre la main sur le
sujet las date était prêt à mobiliser 30
enquêteurs qu'ils étaient prêts à être
projeté sur roman en fonction des
instructions du procureur et donc c'est
vraiment un sujet qui pour nous est
particulièrement important et sur lequel
nous restons totalement mobilisé pour
faire en sorte qu'on puisse répondre à
chacune des sollicitations
dès lors que nous avons besoin est que
nous puissions sur ces sujets être en
permanence armée sur cela et la lutte
antiterroriste en général reste à un
haut niveau de mobilisation je vous
rappelle les soixante et un attentat
déjoué depuis 2000 13-19 attentes a
échoué aussi et le fait que tous nos
dispositifs continue à fonctionner et je
pense en particulier aux jets d'eau j'ai
fait vérifier que les jeunes puissent
continuer à être actif dans chaque
département même si je sais que les
préfets sont mobilisés sur d'autres
sujets parce que on ne peut pas baisser
la garde
la question plus précise d'eric ciotti
vise elle est globale j'y reviendrai
mais elle vise aussi en particulier les
sortants de prison
je crois que la garde des sceaux hier à
recadrer des éléments qu'ils aient été
sortis dans la presse d'hier et qui
n'étaient pas exacts et a précisé ce
dont il en est est ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que aucun détenu pour des
faits de terrorisme n'a été libérés dans
le cadre de l' ordonnance que la garde
des sceaux vous a présenté hier
ce que je sais aussi c'est que healy a
actuellement en prison et au 3 avril
2020 il y avait huit cent cinquante
trois individus incarcérés pour des
infractions de droit commun est suivie
aussi pour leur radicalisation et nous
avons mis en place un dispositif
spécifique pour accompagner la sortie
quel que soit le cadre de la sortie y
compris la fin de peine la sortie de
chacun avec l'ensemble de nos services
pour que nous puissions avoir une
communication suffisante pour que tous
soit contrôlé vérifié et accompagner le
terme n'est pas juridique mais chacun
ici le comprendra au moment de leur
sortie quand ils doivent sortir
il ne m'appartient pas de me prononcer
sur les sorties vous les connaissez les
prévisions de libération pour des tice
sont connus les prévisions de libération
pour des personnes radicaliser sont
connus par nos services
et donc nous les accompagnons de façon
systématique sur ces sujets et jed
contribuer à cela ils se réunissent
toujours jeudi les me casse demeurent
des mesures toujours adaptés et new
services ont continué à produire des me
casser la présidente de la commission
des lois a évoqué le fait qu évident ces
sujets remonter jusqu'à vous et nous
veillons à être totalement mobilisé pour
que nous ne baissons pas la garde sur le
risque terroriste parce que nous avons
effectivement qu'il existe et qu'il est
encore présent plus globalement sur les
risques anticipée d'un confinement long
en matière de sécurité d'ordre public
c'est le sens aussi de la question
d'eric ciotti
il ya plusieurs risques d'abord risque à
court terme la perte d'adhésion
progressive de la population aux mesures
de confinement
ça c'est une difficulté à laquelle nous
devons faire face et sur lequel nous
devons être attentifs
il ya pendant cette période-là des
risques des risques qui sont liées à
l'augmentation dès violences urbaines
dans les quartiers en particulier
ça n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui même
s'il y a quand même des violences
urbaines dans les quartiers mais nous ne
sommes pas un niveau qui soit anormal
problème c'est que je pense que dès le
premier acte on est déjà dans la
normalité mais il n'empêche que hélas
les violences urbaines se produisent
dans les quartiers et qu'il n'y a pas de
conséquence du confinement sur une
augmentation des violences urbaines
je peux vous dire que c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle pour les observateurs
parce que quand il ya des vacances
scolaires par exemple on a une
augmentation des violences urbaines
parce qu'on est des jeunes + 2 vrai dans
la journée qui commettent ces actes là
ça n'est pas le cas au moment où je vous
parle c'est un sujet sur lequel nous
veillons en particulier et puis on
connaît aussi d'autres types de
conséquences que l'on pourrait avoir du
fait du confinement
parmi ces conséquences là moi je
m'inquiète de la montée de nouvelles
formes de délinquance
d'abord celle que l'on connaît et qui
s'aggrave les violences
infra
il yal pendant cette période est celle
qui se développe aussi lié aux
opportunités je pense aux escroqueries
par internet
je crains aussi le risque de
communautarisme et qui est le comité
risme puisse se développer
l'organisation du renforcement
communautaire dans une période d'une
société doute est quelque chose auquel
tous les pays ont pu faire face et donc
du coup c'est un sujet qui peut
provoquer du repli sur soi et peut
provoquer du repli communautaire c'est
un sujet de préoccupation que nous
suivons et que nous analysons pour nous
préparer à la sortie du confinement le
moment venu et puis aussi des pratiques
religieuses par exemple et savvis
plusieurs religions qui font que pour
pâques
on se rassemble pour le ramadan au
moment de la rupture du jeûne on se
rassemble autant de sujets qui
pourraient être en confrontation avec
les règles du confinement et donc nous
observons évidemment cela et nous nous
préparons de la même façon les réseaux
d'ultra droite et les réseaux d'ultra
gauche où la mouvance ultra gauche est
très active sur les réseaux sociaux sur
en ce moment et apple a préparé un
certain nombre d'actes qu'ils voudraient
commettre à la sortie de l'agréable du
confinement ou de la crise et donc c'est
autant de sujets sur lequel est jeune
elle n'aborde pas tout je voudrais pas
trop longtemps sujet sur lequel nous
fait particulièrement mobilisés
particulièrement vigilant à la question
précise d'eric ciotti sur les cra je
n'ai pas souhaité peut-être que d'autres
m'interrogeant sur ce sujet en disant
que nous aurions dû le faire je n'ai pas
souhaité fermer les cra parce qu'il y à
l'intérieur des sortants de prison parce
qu'il y à l'intérieur des gens qui sont
connus pour avoir provoqué des troubles
manifeste à l'ordre public parce que
nous continuons à procéder dans certains
cas il est vrai que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile à des expulsions à des
exécutions d'obligation de quitter le
territoire et donc au moment où je vous
parle il ya 184 personnes qui sont
présents dans les cra le conseil d'état
je vous l'indiquais a été saisie pour
obtenir la fermeture des cra le conseil
d'état a considéré que les mesures que
nous avons mises en oeuvre au sein des
cra ne permettaient pas de considérer
que la santé de ceux qui étaient dans
les cra été menacés et donc s'il ya
quelques cra qui ont été fermés parce
que leur taux d'occupation était
inférieure à 10% ça n'est pas le cas
pour l'essentiel leur activité se
poursuit il
r il ya quatorze personnes qui ont été
placées en cra et ça concerne en
particulier des étrangers en situation
irrégulière qui sortait de prison et
peut-être d'ailleurs que c'est un
élément de réponse à la question qui
était posée précédemment mais là ma
réponse n'est pas statistiques quand je
vous dis cela
marielle de sarnez a abordé la dimension
européenne je suis va rejoindre et sur
son caractère essentiel ce que je peux
vous livrer pour avoir participé à
quelques réunions sauvés sous forme
j'aille à des ministres de l'intérieur
c'est que la prise de conscience du
risque a été assez tardive
j'ai le souvenir d'avoir participé à un
jet à bruxelles à un moment où nous
pratiquions déjà les gestes de de
distanciation social en france
et j'étais assez surpris du comportement
de certains de mes interlocuteurs qui
n'étaient pas dans cette conscience là à
ce moment là et donc quand on a abordé
le sujet entre ministre de l'intérieur
sous l'autorité et en lien de la
commission on a bien vu qu'au fond ce
n'était pas un sujet de préoccupation au
moment où nous demandions des mesures
communes et partagées sur sur ce sujet
là ensuite il ya eu évidemment ce que
nous connaissons et la prise de
conscience totale de chacun des pays
et là aussi des organisations cyr que
chaque pays après d'initiatives qui
n'ont pas été coordonnés ou régulée par
la commission européenne qui nappe est
en capacité de le faire
ce que je peux vous dire ma mère est
présente c'est que du côté français
nous avons veillé à chaque fois qu'il
s'agisse dans l'ordre de l'italie de
l'allemagne de l'espagne puis de la
belgique est en lien c'est un peu
particulier avec le royaume uni à ce que
de façon systématique les décisions
soient coordonnés anticipé en 24 heures
est mise en oeuvre en commun avec des
mesures de réciprocité le visant a
toujours protégé les transfrontaliers
qui travaillait et donc c'est vraiment
ça a vraiment été la règle sur ce que
nous devons faire
s'agissant des perspectives à moyen
terme c'est le sens de votre question je
n'ai pas d'éléments de réponse mais si
la stabilisation était parfaitement
homogène dans l'espace européen
les airs les restrictions actuelles aux
frontières intérieures européenne
pourrait être levé et si l inverse on
voit qu'on a des foyers pandémie
il subsiste en europe après la maîtrise
du coc vite dans l'hexagone nous
pourrions privilégier soit des contraire
des contrôles à nos frontières
nationales soit l'établissement de
contrôle par tous nos partenaires
européens avec ceux des états membres le
virus reste en circulation active
voilà ce que je veux ce que je peux
préciser par rapport à nos réflexions
david habib a évoqué plusieurs sujets
dont le sujet du préfet de police
je voulais être clair sur ce sujet si
monsieur habib considère que c'est un
sujet prioritaire au moment de cette
audition le préfet de police a dit les
faits inexacts
maladroit et fo qui ont pu heurter
profondément ce qu'ils ont entendu il a
regretté ses propos il a confirmé qu'ils
étaient inexactes il s'en est excusé ce
que moi j'attends du préfet de police
c'est qu'il soit totalement engagé dans
les priorités que je lui donne et parmi
ses priorités il y a effectivement le
respect du confinement mais pas
seulement de respectueux confinement
mais nous l'avons vu ce week-end il a
fait en sorte que l'ensemble des
effectifs de la préfecture de pluie
soient mobilisés sur le terrain et c'est
cela que j'attends de lui sur les
masques je crois que vous n'avez pas
bien entendu mon propos liminaire mais
il est vrai que il y ait un désaccord
sur la doctrine certaines organisations
syndicales ont demandé à ce que tous les
policiers soient équipés en permanence
le masque ce n'est pas la doctrine
nationale qui a été arrêté sous
l'autorité du ministère de la santé et
des solidarités ce n'est pas la doctrine
nationale que nous appliquons
aujourd'hui mais la demande avait été
bien entendu bien avant le 23 mars que
vous évoquez le 9 mars
j'ai présenté cette doctrine elle a été
présentée aux différentes autorités du
ministère aux organisations syndicales
le 13 mars mais parler du 23 mars le 13
mars l'instruction de la pitié dgpn a
été donnée le 16 mars instructions du
dieu gn a été donné et le 23 mars
c'était le jour de la rencontre avec le
professeur salomon pour expliciter la
doctrine il n'a pas convaincu les
organisations syndicales je vous le
confirme
mais il m'appartient d'appliquer la
doctrine nationale est pas une doctrine
ministérielle qui se ferait à
rencontre de la doctrine nationale je
suis sûr que sur ce sujet nous nous
retrouvons j'ai bien noté votre remarque
sur le fait que le ps n'avait jamais
demandé le maintien des élections
municipales
alors monsieur habib le ps je ne sais
pas par contre olivier faure a déclaré
le 12 mars
il n'y a pas plus de raisons d'avoir
peur d'aller voter que d'aller prendre
le métro le rer que d'aller au travail
il n'y a pas plus de promiscuité deux
points on rentre en général seul dans
l'isoloir
c'est la même règle donc je ne sais pas
comment je dois interpréter vos propos
sur le parti socialiste mais il me
semble que le premier secrétaire du
parti ce site n'a pas tout à fait le
même sentiment que le vôtre sur le fait
qu'il n'ai jamais demandé le maintien
deux opérations de vote plus globalement
enfin la question qui m'étaient posées
par olive et belge sur les moyens de la
police c'était on a réorienté en
fonction des réalités auxquelles nous
devons faire face les priorités
le petit judiciaire aujourd'hui dès lors
que l'organisation du ministère de la
justice a changé pour prendre en compte
les difficultés de fonctionnement liés
aux qu'ovide le petit judiciaire et
moins une priorité pour faire simple
respect du confinement est un engagement
total de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure respect de nos frontières
faisant partie du respect du confinement
et de la protection fait partie aussi de
ses dimensions la respect de tout ce qui
relève des troubles de voie publique
mais aussi mobilisation plus forte
encore et je ne vais pas détailler pour
être trop long mais peut-être que des
questions viendront sur les sujets sur
lequel nous savons que des femmes des
enfants sont en risque
je pense aux violences intrafamiliales
et ensuite pour tous ceux qui au du
spectre
évidemment il n'est pas question que
nous puissions répondre que nous sommes
mobilisés sur le confinement
quand il ya des faits importants de
troubles à l'ordre public quand il ya
des faits importants de deux
cambriolages
deux menaces de vols divers et variés et
quand il ya des menaces subversive dans
nos pays pourrait faire l'objet
ça fait partie évidemment de nos
priorités merci monsieur le ministre je
passe la parole maintenant monsieur
philippe vigier président du groupe
liberté et territoires vous avez la
parole chers collègues on ne vous entend
pas chers collègues
excusez moi on ne vous entend pas est ce
que le micro est bien enclenchée bonjour
monsieur le président voilà ce que si on
vous entend déjà mes chers collègues
bonjour monsieur le ministre
tous les soirs nous applaudissons
chaleureusement l'ensemble du personnel
soignant je vais vous dire monsieur le
ministre que nous remercions l'ensemble
des personnels qu'ils se pensent ou
votre responsabilité
si les gendarmes pompiers et tous les
personnels des préfectures mobilisés
dans la lutte contre le coc vide sur le
tracking j'aimerais vous entendre
puisque c'est un des moyens de lutte
contre la propagation du virus
envisagez-vous à court terme la mise en
place d'un track in quel sera le rôle du
parlement dans cet épisode là comment
préserver vous la liberté individuelle
y aura-t-il une coordination européenne
le conseil d'état at il est déjà été
destinataire d'un texte ma seconde
question concernant l'évolution de la
doctrine sur vos personnels exposés ils
ont payé un lourd tribut au co vite vous
rappeler monsieur le ministre je vous
rappelle simplement que l'académie
nationale de médecine a préconisé le p
ascq et vous croyez pas que nouveau
personnel qui tous les jours avec
exigences font ce travail que vous leur
demandez doivent être avant tout tous
protégés en toutes circonstances enfin
sur le respect du confinement à
plusieurs reprises nous avons alerté
notamment avec françois pupponi député
du val d'oise parce qu'il sent que dans
les banlieues souvent ce confinement
n'est pas toujours respectée avez vous
donné des comptes des consignes très
fermes pour qu'ils puissent être
respectées car seul le confinement nous
permettra de lutter efficacement contre
ce virus
je vous en remercie merci monsieur le
président
la parole est à madame mathilde de
panneaux pour le groupe de la france
insoumise merci monsieur le ministre la
lutte contre le corona virus ne justifie
pas d'utiliser des technologies de
surveillance de masse monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur et nous en
sommes capables de concevoir votre rôle
autrement que comme le ministre de la
répression
les états d'urgence pour faire face au
terrorisme déjà été l'occasion de
régression de portes des libertés
publiques
vous essayez maintenant d'utiliser
l'état d'urgence sanitaire pour de
nouvelles atteintes aux libertés à la
protection des données personnelles et à
la vie privée
cette fuite en avant sécuritaire est
inacceptable dans notre démocratie
d'ailleurs vous semblez changer
facilement d'avis puisque vous disiez le
26 mars
cela n'est pas dans la culture française
je fais confiance aux français pour que
nous n'ayons pas à mettre en place ces
systèmes qui appelle la liberté
individuelle de chacun
donc ce n'est pas un sujet sur lequel
nous travaillons pourtant après
l'utilisation de drones vous indiquez
travailler à une application pour
téléphone portable de traçage numérique
l'efficacité de ce traçage hidhab est
d'abord loin d'être démontrée à
singapour l'état qui organise une
surveillance très forte de la population
via les smartphones importants étaient
obligés de passer au confinement
généralisée ensuite ce traçage numérique
est dangereux ou seront admises et les
données pendant combien de temps sur
l'hôtel gardé où est la notion de
consentement libre avec la pression
patronale ou sociales qui pourraient
exister avec une telle application
éventuellement imposer pour continuer de
travailler ou pour accéder à certains
lieux publics sans parler de l'atteinte
au secret médical
d'autant que cette application serait
discriminatoire 44% des personnes de
plus de 70 ans possible ne possède pas
peut-être téléphone portable seulement
44% en possède par lui et 14 % des
français ont des difficultés pour passer
des appels ou envoyer les sms exclut les
personnes âgées les personnes en réalité
les précaires enfin ou et le volontariat
si c'est le seul moyen d'accéder à des
tests de nombreuses organisations
s'élèvent contre ce solutio nisme
technologiques dont la quadrature du net
les doigts
mongrain magistrature monsieur le
ministre le traçage numérique n'est
qu'une manière d'individualiser la lutte
contre le choléra qui ne laisse premier
masquer l'odeur est votre incapacité
gouvernementales à première des tests et
des mâles franchise mal quand nombre
suffisant ne nous surveiller pas
dépister fournissez des masques aux
policiers planifié mais laisser
tranquille nos libertés merci madame pas
nous la parole est à monsieur stéphane
peu pour le groupe de la gauche
démocrate et républicaine monsieur peut
vous avez la parole oui merci monsieur
le président monsieur le préfet à mon
tour je devrais vous dire quand le conte
se félicite en seine saint denis du
travail qui s'est instauré entre la
préfecture le préfet et l'ensemble des
parlementaires et des élus mais je pense
que cet avis et cette satisfaction sur
l'excellence du travail la transparence
des relations chacun dans son rôle doit
être partagée par l'ensemble des maires
des parlementaires mais il ya quelques
jours monsieur le ministre le président
de la république et le gouvernement ont
décidé de démettre de ses fonctions le
directeur de la rs du grand est qui
avait tenu des propos extrêmement
critique est discutable et qui avait
créé le trouble dans la région vous avez
évoqué le préfet de police l'allemand
mais je vais le je vais leur père est
soupçonné ce n'est pas dans notre genre
de faire des d'avoir des attaques
personnelles ou des propos personnalisé
mais là trop c'est trop les propos du
préfet d'allemands sont absolument
inqualifiable il a expliqué que les gens
qui est en réanimation l'étaient parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas respecté les règles
du confinement parce qu'ils avaient
désobéi dans son élan il aurait pu
parler d'une sanction divine contre ce
qui aurait péché ces propos profondément
choqué l'ensemble des français est
choqué la communauté médicale beaucoup
de deux médecins qui sont aujourd'hui
dans les services de réanimation dont on
sait que 50 % des gens vont faire vibrer
un mineur de réanimation peuvent mourir
ont demandé la démission de ce prêt de
chez et ont trouvé absolument
inqualifiable ses propos quand on est
dans une période de crise comme on est
actuellement de guerre pour reprendre
les propos du président de la république
on ne peut pas avoir des hauts fonds
soner qui tire dans le dos de l'effort
que concentre toute la nation en premier
lieu les médecins bien sûr les
personnels soignants mais aussi les
policiers les services préfectoraux
donc ces propos du préfet d'altran sont
à la fois et on sont aussi ceux d'un
multirécidiviste de propos qui éloigne
le préfet de police de paris
d'une conception d'une police
républicaine à laquelle nous sommes tous
attachés
entendez-vous avoir autant de rester
aussi discret dans les semaines les
jours les semaines et les mois qui
viennent vis-à-vis de ce préfet qui
visiblement n'est pas à sa place
merci monsieur peu la parole est à
monsieur jean rené cazeneuve
pour le groupe la république en 28' la
parole
on ne vous entend pas chers collègues on
ne vous entend pas nous montrons les
larmes
oui là ça va oui merci monsieur le
président le sully ils seraient les
reçoit une crise sanitaire d'une ampleur
inouïe et je voudrais saluer le rôle
primordial des élus locaux les maires
les conseillers municipaux mais aussi
les élus des intercoms et départements
des régions qui se sont mobilisés aux
côtés des services des courants pour
faire appliquer les mesures de
confinement organiser les solidarités
soutenir les l'activité économique les
exemples sont multiples il joue un rôle
central dans la gestion de cette crise
ils le font parce que leur dévouement sa
vie des français est leur raison d'être
ils le font aussi parce que nous
constituons rien ne comprendrait pas que
nous ne soyons pas uni pour lutter
contre cette pandémie et l'intervention
des élus sont d'autant plus efficaces
qu'elles se font en concertation étroite
et permanente avec eux l'état et quand
exceptionnellement elle ne le faisait
pas ils ont d'ailleurs créé de la
confusion je pense un salon deux
initiatives sur les masques tenir ces
deux questions la première le décret
pris en conseil des ministres hier
renforce le pouvoir de dérogation des
préfets
c'est une excellente mesure
particulièrement adaptés on prend des
décisions locales avec les élus jugent
mais ne craignez vous pas une
incompréhension des français à des
mesures qui par définition ne serez pas
nationale deuxième question face à la
crise le gouvernement a décidé le
maintien des exécutifs municipaux et
communautaires et adopté plusieurs
ordonnances permettant d'assurer la
gouvernance ainsi que la gestion
financière et budgétaire de ces astuces
sur le cac il était important d'avoir
des équipes aguerries
de toute façon la dégradation de la
situation sanitaire ne berne ne
permettait plus l'installation de
nouveaux conseils et ça marche
anciens et futurs élus travaillent
globalement en très bonne intelligence
mais si le second tour devait être
et nous faudrait-il pas aux intercomités
procéder à l'élection d'un exécutif
certes provisoire mais plus légitime et
quel serait le processus démocratique
ob retire un consensus républicain
autour de cette décision merci merci
monsieur cazeneuve
la parole est à monsieur jeu kim sun
forget députés d'en inscrire en vous
entendant su se forger très bien oui
merci
mais celui de l'intérieur je
souhaiterais vous poser de questions une
relative aux à la question la libération
anticipée les prisonniers n'est pas ce
qu'on lit dans la presse que finalement
on a des soucis concernant le suivi de
sa place d'individus radicalisés ou en
tout cas suspects d'être dangereux ou de
récits bible ou passage à l'acte quel
qu'il soit et je voulais savoir ce qu'il
en est concernant cette question
concernant éventuellement justement des
ruptures de capacité
concernant le suivi par vos services de
renseignements de certains individus
dangereux dans le contexte où je crois
que tout le monde craint un nouvel
épisode où il au lait ou organisés tels
que celui qu'on a pu vivre les derniers
jours par ailleurs concernant le
matériel de protection je prends bonne
note que vous avez fait des commandes
massives de matériel pour vous pour les
pour les fonctionnaires je j'entends que
vous avez commandé aussi des lunettes de
protection
la question est pourquoi est ce qu'il ya
un besoin massif de plusieurs de
dizaines de millions d'unités dans ce
registre
alors que normalement - chaque policier
donc personnel de notamment armés il
donne normalement disposer chacun d'une
paire de lunettes de protection adaptées
situation pourquoi des pourquoi de tel
manque donc je ne peux pas pas du reste
des matches je comprends comme tout le
monde la difficulté à laquelle on a dû
faire face
mais dans le contexte de ces autres
équipements je suis surpris d'entendre
qu'on ne les a pas déjà à disposition
je remercie pour vos réponses merci cher
qu'avec monsieur le ministre pour 7
deuxième série de questions vous avez la
parole merci sur le président philippe
vigier et le tracking
je crois qu'il ya une audition hier de
cédric haut et qui a présenté un
scénario central téléchargement
volontaire et prévention et maîtrise des
risques de contamination et en vous
disant cela je vous dis très clairement
que le ministère de l'intérieur n'est
pas concerné par les opérations de
tracking que ce dispositif ne relève pas
des attributions à des missions du
ministère de l'intérieur nous sommes sur
un outil sanitaires et prophylactiques
ce n'est pas un fichier de sécurité et
s'ils étaient mises en place et je n'ai
aucun avis sur le sujet les forces de
sécurité intérieure veillerez si le
législateur décidé qu'il faille faire un
contrôle que le contrôle soit fait point
et je voudrais vraiment insister sur ce
sujet et ça me permet de répondre à ce
qui n'était pas une question mais une
déclaration de mathilde panneau avant de
me traiter de ministre de la répression
regardons les compétences des uns et des
autres et ça n'est pas une compétence
ministérielle sur ce sujet et regardons
d'ailleurs et écoutons ce que j'ai pu
dire que je veux bien qu'on me prête
beaucoup de choses la question qui m'a
été posée sur un outil de ce type là
pour veiller à la surveillance du
confinement j'ai répondu que je faisais
appel à l'intelligence des français je
pensais qu'elle était nécessaire je
continue de penser que l'intelligence
des français est au rendez vous dans le
respect du confinement est d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d'études ont été faites
montrent que la france est parmi les
pays du monde qui respecte le mieux le
confinement les français font partie de
ceux qui respectent le mieux le
confinement au monde par rapport aux
études qui ont été publiés par google
sur l'utilisation et la gestion de ses
données et donc voilà je veux bien
entendre les procès j'y suis habitué de
la part de m'a dit madame panneaux mais
très clairement je veux réaffirmer une
chose simple ce dispositif ne relèvera
pas des attributions et des missions du
ministère d'odeur et je crois que le
fait d'affirmer cela est déjà un élément
de réponse à l'esprit dans lequel
aujourd'hui il y a des études qui sont
faites sur ce sujet et qu'évidemment
vous offre l'occasion de poursuivre ces
échanges avec ceux qui sont compétents
sur
ce sujet ce n'est pas le cas du ministre
de l'intérieur
stéphane peut vous avez commencé en
saluant en m'appelant monsieur le préfet
j'ai cru que c'était un compliment mais
vu la fin de votre propos je crains que
ce ne sera pas le cas plus sérieusement
je me suis déjà prononcé sur les propos
du préfet didier lallement il s'est déjà
prononcé sur ce sujet voulait retenir
certains professionnels de santé qui se
sont indignés à juste titre de ses
propos
bonjour de retenir les propos du
professeur carli qui immédiatement après
la déclaration du préfet l'allemand le
vendredi après midi lui a donné acte et
lui a renouvelé sa confiance parce qu'il
a l'habitude de travailler avec lui je
pense que on va pas choisir les médecins
sur lesquels on s'appuie une chose est
sûre c'est que le préfet a regretté ses
propos qui était une faute il l'a dit et
il l'a fait de la façon la plus claire
je pense que dans le contexte de tension
que chacun connaît parlementaires
ministres fonctionnaires sur le terrain
on peut accepter aussi qu'il puisse y
avoir des moments où on peut avoir sa
longue qui dit une grosse bêtise et ce
qui compte c'est notre capacité à s'en
excuser elle a corrigé tout de suite je
sens vraiment chez le préfet l'allemand
cette conscience là je vous le dis c'est
évidemment un sujet que j'ai pu aborder
avec lui immédiatement et ensuite
pendant le week-end et j'ai pris note de
son engagement sur ce sujet de ses
propos sur ce sujet et je pense que ça
n'enlève rien à l'exigence que vous
portez dans votre question et je sais
votre sens républicain monsieur le
député peut l'exigence sur d'autres
sujets et je crois que ces exigences
sont plus forte encore sur le préfet
l'allemand au moment où vous me posez
cette question jean rené cazeneuve a
interrogé sûr je sais pas si j'ai
répondu à toutes et quid du budget oui
non philippe vigier vous m'avez abordés
et oui c'est ça il me semblait que
j'avais oublié un sujet le sujet délicat
du confinement et des banlieues
sensibles jeudi délicat parce que
d'abord mais c'était pas le sens de
votre question
évidemment j'ai vu que certains se
précipitaient pour faire le procès à la
banlieue quartiers difficiles comme si
les jeunes étaient forcément crétin est
incapable de comprendre qu' il était
aussi par bill
premier à être menacée par le caue vite
et ce que nous avons vu massivement
c'est un respect des règles du
confinement y compris dans les quartiers
mais ce que je sais aussi c'est qu'il
est beaucoup plus difficile dans
certains lieux de respecter le
confinement dans d'autres jeux opposé
tout à l'heure un appartement avec une
famille vous n'avez pas forcément un
abonnement à netflix jeu pas citer de
marque mais tous les abonnements
possibles chacun ayant une tablette et
chacun pouvant avoir des loisirs en
sortant dans son jardin et en ayant une
très jolie vue par rapport à la
difficulté de vivre dans un immeuble
dans un quartier bétonné et je sais
c'est réalité là et donc il faut les
prendre en compte mais ce que je sais
c'est que nous n'avons pas été
confrontés à des rassemblement massifs
d'individus provoquant les forces de
l'ordre
il ya eu des incidents il ya eu des
incidences ce week-end par exemple dans
les yvelines je pense à la trappe ou à
mantes la jolie
il ya eu des incidents à torcy à clichy
sous bois en seine saint denis
et puis il ya des incidents à mayotte
assez régulier hélas mais il ya eu des
incidents
je ne veux pas les les contester et
souvent traces qui se transforment en
violences urbaines en provocation
vis-à-vis des forces de sécurité et
représailles aussi des verbalisations
pour le non respect des mesures de
confinement
donc évidemment nous devons lutter
activement contre parce que c'est
insupportable et que ce n'est pas
acceptable mais nous devons lutter
activement contre parce que ce sont ces
jeunes là qu'ils seront demain les
premières victimes du coc vide et qui du
coup en étant victime fragiliseront
l'ensemble du combat que tout le monde
mène mais je note aussi que certains ça
parfaitement détourné la loi et les
exceptions dans les quartiers cossus de
paris donc voilà le noeud ça n'était pas
le sens de votre question restons
vigilants mais ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que nos forces sont présentes
partout
jean rené cazeneuve et rapidement sur la
place des élus je me suis exprimé tout à
l'heure en répondant à la question des
albums privé yann il ya deux ans je
éviter le risque de désordre 7 est le
sens de votre question mais faire
confiance aux territoires et c'est la
politique de différenciation que nous
prenons et que nous voulons mettre en
oeuvre
c'est ce point d'équilibré il y a des
lignes qu'il ne faut pas franchir
je pense que les deux arrêtés que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure tous été prise
hier et qui rendent obligatoire le port
du masque sans pour autant
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une détermination
scientifiques exactes et partagée par
tous qui permettent d'y voir clair
serait une erreur sur ce sujet là et
donc du coup il me paraît important de
faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas d'excès
pour éviter le désordre mais qu'il y ait
une confiance dans les territoires et
dans les élus et puis vous poser la
question de la gestion de cette
situation provisoire pour les exécutifs
je sais qu'elle est délicat pour ce qui
me concerne
seule la loi ma réponse est celle ci
seule la loi peut permettre d'organiser
les choses différemment et donc il vous
appartiendra d'en décider
sur la question de yoakim sorte forgé
sur la libération anticipée des
prisionniers gj répondu précédemment
mais je veux vraiment insisté sur le
fait qu' on a des dispositifs de suivi
des sortants de prison
ces dispositifs sont toujours
opérationnels et des services de
renseignement sont pleinement mobilisés
nous savons que la menace carcérale est
protéiforme
c'est une menace pour l'environnement
carcéral c'est une menace projeté depuis
les lieux de détention et c'est une
menace liés au prosélytisme religieux de
personnes incarcérées et donc on a mis
en place des dispositifs pour prendre en
compte cette menace c'est la création et
la montée en puissance du fnrp le
service du renseignement pénitentiaire
c'est la cellule de suivi des sortants
de prison de la dg à six qui demeure
totalement mobilisé sur ce sujet et je
peux vous dire que récemment à la tenue
deux visioconférences exceptionnelle
pour anticiper les sorties de prison que
la garde des sceaux ait évoqué devant
vous hier mais aussi les sorties de
prison régulière qu'elle a évoqué aussi
devant vous c'est l'activation des
groupes d'évaluation départementaux et
je peux vous dire que 60 de ged se sont
tenues depuis le début du confinement et
donc c'est vraiment un sujet sur lequel
personne ne baisse les bras
nous sommes au niveau de mobilisation
est malgré tout ça ne garantit pas que
nous puissions empêcher des situations
comme celle que nous avons connue à
romans sur isère avec une personne qui
n'est jamais apparu dans aucun des
spectres que nous connaissons qui
rentrait en france en 2016 que même
processus de reconnaissance
la protection et son statut de réfugié
un processus d'accompagnement et
d'intégration notamment avec le
dispositif up qui est un dispositif dont
on est plutôt fier on voit son
efficacité en matière d'intégration
et pourtant à sept personnes ont été
attaquées et deux sont décédées et puis
vous me posez une question de technique
sur les lunettes de protection il faut
faire la différence entre les nets qui
sont liées à celles pour l'entraînement
au tir et les lunettes qui sont des
lunettes de protection pour les sorties
et pour les interventions sur la voie
publique
mais oui j'ai oublié un sujet ah oui sur
le décret pouvoir de dérogation c'est
vrai que c'était un peu coupé et voilà
c'est un sujet qui est bien connu tout
vous et de nous il a été travaillée en
profondeur avec la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales moi je ne
crois pas que les français sont
inquiètes
c'est vraiment le motif d'intérêt
général qui doit justifier les
dérogations les recours sont possibles
et on l'a utilisé dans l'expérimentation
183 fois ces deux dernières années dans
17 départements et c'est parce que cette
expérimentation a montré à la fois
l'intelligence donné le pouvoir local
d'appréciation par rapport à la norme
nationale que nous avons décidé hier en
conseil des ministres de de l'élargir et
ça me permettrait rapidement de saluer
justement la reconnaissance du travail
des préfets beaucoup de vos
interventions l'ont montré je crois que
ce texte d des premiers depuis quelques
semaines qui n'étaient pas liées à
l'état d'urgence sanitaire et j'en étais
assez fier parce que je crois que c'est
une façon aussi de reconnaître
l'engagement extraordinaire des prêts
faits sur le terrain et beaucoup d'entre
vous l'ont salué et je peux vous
préciser que j'ai demandé dès le début
de la crise à tous les préfets et
j'espère que c'est fait et que vous
pourrez non pas le témoigner maintenant
même le confirmer que dans chaque
département soit mise en place des
vidéos des boucles telegraph ou autre
système pour que les préfets puissent
très régulièrement tenir informé les
parlementaires de leur département
majorité-opposition tous les
parlementaires de leur département de
tout ce qui se passe dans le département
parce que je sais combien ce lien est
important dans les périodes où vous
aussi vous êtes dans l'obligation du
confinement
merci monsieur le ministre et
permettez-moi aussi d'ajouter l'action
des sous préfets qui dans les
arrondissements sens au plus près du
terrain et moi qui ne suis pas élue dans
une circonscription qui compte une ville
préfecture je mesure chaque jour combien
les sous préfet relais l'action de
l'administration et des préfets avec
beaucoup de dévouement et et
d'efficacité la parole est à madame
josiane torno pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président vous
m'entendez très bien parfaitement bien
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
à mon tour salué les élus locaux le
travail qu'il qu'ils exécutent les
maires mais aussi les élus
départementaux régionaux et qui avec les
préfets les sous-préfets réalise un
travail tout à fait remarquable aux
côtés des soignants pour lutter de façon
efficace contre cette pandémie
les pompiers également et les forces de
l'ordre auquel je tiens à rendre hommage
sont depuis le début de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire en première ligne pour lutter
contre cette pandémie le devoir
prioritaire de la dation pour aider tous
ses personnels dans leur lourde tâche
c'est de préserver leur santé en les
dotant d'équipements de protection
sanitaire individuelles notamment bien
évidemment des masques des gants et des
lunettes
or le 27 février dernier la fédération
nationale des sapeurs-pompiers de france
jugeait inacceptable de ne pas
bénéficier de masques de protection ni
d'être testé au coït 19
par ailleurs depuis fin février les
policiers également alerte le
gouvernement concernant le manque de
masques et les risques qu'ils encourent
vous l'avez évoqué le mercredi 25 mars
votre ministère a demandé aux policiers
de rendre leurs masques ffp2 aux agences
régionales de santé et j'ai envie de
dire quand bien même les policiers et
les gendarmes disposaient de masquer la
façon d utiliser m'interroge puisque le
secrétaire d'état laurent à lunesse de
mais nous leur demandons de revêtir le
masque à chaque fois qu'il contrôle des
individus qui peuvent leur sembler
symptomatique est uniquement à ce moment
là comment cela peut-il être possible
comment un policier lors d'un contrôle
peut apprécier au nom du corona virus
désormais le directeur général de la
santé encourage le grand public à porter
des masques
donc nous le voyons c'est le flou ce
sont des ordres des contre ordres qui
ont dominé jusque là et je pense
clairement que contrairement aux
déclarations du gouvernement
la france ne disposez pas de stocks
suffisants et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils ont été longtemps réservée
au personnel soyez en vérité monsieur
ministre aucun plan de préservation des
forces de secours et des forces de
l'ordre n'a été prévu alors
qu'aujourd'hui des mères nous voyons
pour faillite a commencé à prendre des
arrêtés qui impose de port obligatoire
des masques pouvez vous nous assurez
monsieur le ministre
aujourd'hui les forces de l'ordre et de
secours dispose de tous les équipements
nécessaires
vous avez dit qu'ils étaient commandés
sont ils merci chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur jean-noël
barrot pour le groupe du mouvement
démocrate et apparentés
merci monsieur le président un bonjour
monsieur le ministre je voudrais vous
interrogez d'abord sur la question des
marchés et des jardins familiaux
plus particulièrement on comprend
évidemment les les impératifs sanitaires
qui ont conduit les préfets sous votre
autorité à prendre des décisions de
fermeture sur ces marchés extérieurs et
sur les jardins familiaux
néanmoins ne serait-il pas possible
d'envisager qu'une réflexion puisse être
mené pour définir au cas par cas les
conditions d'organisation dans
lesquelles ces structures pourraient
être réouverte
il ya évidemment la question du débouché
pour pour nos agriculteurs concernant
les marchés et pour les jardins
familiaux il ya aussi une question de la
capacité de des ménages ou des foyers
les plus modestes qui s'appuie sur ses
jardins premio pour se nourrir de
continuer à le faire
alors que la période de confinement se
prolonge j'ai ensuite deux questions
s'agissant de l'asile et de
l'immigration vous avez déjà évoqué dans
les réponses que vous avez apporté aux
questions des collègues sur la question
des transferts dublin la france
envisage-t-elle de suspendre l'exécution
de ces transferts comme certains pays
l'ont fait notamment l'italie et plus
récemment l'allemagne puis sur la
question de l'évacuation des campements
à la suite de ces opérations quelles
règles sanitaires sont appliquées dans
les lieux d'hébergement retenu notamment
lorsqu'il s'agit d' espaces collectifs
comme les gymnases
certaines associations ont récemment
souligné les risques sanitaires posés
par la promiscuité observés dans ces
gymnases comment s'organise le
confinement dans ces lieux d'accueil
je vous remercie merci monsieur barreau
la parole est à madame cécile untermaier
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur ni simplement très rapidement
voulu dire quand même en réaction à la
réponse que vous avez fait mon collègue
david habib qu'on peut résumer le jamais
d'un accord d'achat de parts qui à
partir d'une expression qui date du 9
mars alors que le confinement n'était
pas décidé que le 12 mars seulement la
question n'avait pas été encore
s'unissent à ces derniers mais ceci dit
ma question
elle est d'abord et après avoir remercié
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
intérieure l'ensemble des fonctionnaires
qui travaillent à vos côtés et les
préfets et les sous-préfets des
remercier et de vous dire que il nous
aide beaucoup dans cette période
extrêmement douloureuse je ma question
il porte sur les masques un pont aérien
va être mise en place et déjà mises en
place et c'est très bien mais nous avons
constaté des problèmes à l'arrivée en
particulier sur l'aéroport de bâle
mulhouse fribourg par deux fois de
commandes de la bourgogne franche comté
qui avait été pourtant prise en accord
avec l'agencé régionale de santé ont été
réquisitionnés alors sur le principe de
la réquisition nous avons il n'avons
rien à dire
6 c'est l'urgence il n'y a pas de
problème et je ferai quand même une
observation c'est que ce tout cela donne
une impression quand même de chaos
logistique en plus sa compagne ans
d'absence de fair play puisque la
présidente de franche comté a appris par
l'importateur que la réquisition avait
été fait et non pas par le préfet de la
région un contest et donc on a le
sentiment de chaos de commandes
multiples et quand il y a plusieurs
commandes
est ce qu'il y à un commandement donc ma
question à savoir si l'organisation est
elle au niveau de la situation et est ce
que vous envisagez de et bien de la
révision merci madame antérieur la
parole est à monsieur le président jean
christophe lagarde pour le groupe udi
agir et indépendant merci monsieur le
président je souhaiterais d'abord
monsieur milices nous interroger sur les
violences intrafamiliales d'augmentation
nous inquiète au savoir est ce que vous
pouvez nous indiquer comment fonctionne
et sur quelle plage horaire le service
sms que vous avez mis en place pouvez
vous nous dire nombre d'interventions
effectuées par les forces de l'ordre
pour ces violences et ce qui est la
teneur de ces interventions par exemple
à ce qu'ils peuvent éloigner
immédiatement le conjoint le baron
violent comme en fait un port porté
plainte le week-end quand comme c'est le
cas dans mon arrondissement de seine
saint denis il n'y a plus de pv au
commissariat local clan de tués vendredi
soir lundi matin depuis plus d'un an
ça c'est la première question deuxième
question sur le respect du confinement
le parlement avait choisi dans la loi
d'urgence sanitaire de fixer les
contraventions de 5e classe de 2500
euros en cas de récidive du non-respect
de confinement vous avez choisi
d'abaisser ce montant à seulement 200
euros en cas de récidive je voudrais
savoir pourquoi
enfin je veux nous interroger sur notre
doctrine en matière de marché aux
comestibles couvert par les grandes
villes les préfets s'abrite derrière le
fait qu' on doit avoir un problème
d'approvisionnement pour qu'il autorise
l'ouverture je voudrais savoir votre
réponse qui est un problème
d'approvisionnement dans ses grandes
lignes est ce que vous considérez b que
300 à 400 mètres devant des supermarchés
constitue un problème
d'approvisionnement surtout quand apte à
une heure où de la tente on trouve
pleurer à cause de ce qu'on voulait
acheter confédéral ne parviennent plus à
répondre effet supermarché eux-mêmes
ahmed ne plus parvenir à assumer toutes
les rues des livraisons à domicile en
proie des marchés à ce train des règles
strictes de risques sanitaires seraient
supérieures à celles qu'ont
supermarché où tout le monde touche les
mêmes qualités même emballage les mêmes
vitrine les fruits et légumes sont en
accès libre
ce qui n'est pas le cas dans des marchés
bien organisés et sécurisé j'ai en fait
et c'est pour ça que je vous interpelle
je me dise le sentiment qu'un certain
nombre de vos préfet craignent en
réalité pour leurs éventuelles
responsabilités pénales s'ils
acceptaient des dérogations légitimer
justifier et sécurisé est-ce que vous
avez les moyens de les rassurer en les
protégeant pour que notre situation
d'approvisionnement qui commencent à
traiter sérieusement puisse s'améliorer
je pense notamment à la mer merci
monsieur le président aussi le ministre
sur ces quatre questions vous avez la
parole
merci peut-être madame corneloup nous a
rejoint qu'en cours de l'intervention
donc j'ai fait des précisions sur le
sujet je pense que le compte-rendu
devrait permettre d'aborder slam ça me
permet de rebondir sur les pompiers
parce qu'effectivement je n'ai pas
évoqué assez leur engagement vous
préciser que depuis le début du mois de
février ses 47 mille interventions
qu'ils ont fait avec des durées qui du
coup sont beaucoup plus longues que
d'habitude compte tenu du principe de
précaution et de protection qui est
nécessaire pour chacun d'entre eux
concernant les pompiers ce sont les dix
qui sont évidemment les autorités
chargées de l'équipement et ce sont les
10 qui applique la doctrine nationale de
précaution je crois sur ces sujets j'ai
bien noté les positions du directeur nom
de l'académie de médecine
j'ai noté aussi il ya deux jours à
nouveau la réitération du directeur de
l' oms qui est une autre autorité il y à
des discussions et c'est toute la
difficulté que nous avons à travailler
sur des bases scientifiques qui peuvent
bouger parce que par nature
l'évaluation du risque d'un point de vue
médical change c'est très compliqué je
le reconnais moi je n'ai pas de
certitudes et donc ce que je fais c'est
d'appliquer les doctrines qui sont
émises par ceux dont c'est le métier et
la compétence je ne suis pas compétent
mois pour évaluer s'il faut tel ou que
tel comportement
par contre je veille à ce qu'il soit
appliqué quand ils sont déterminés par
ceux qui sont en compétences sur ce
sujet
et je voudrais revenir très rapidement
aussi sur les pompiers j'ai rappelé que
c'était le disque était en charge de
l'équipement
mais les consignes étaient très claires
est donnée au préfet pour que ceux ci se
mettent à la disponibilité des
présidents et des directeurs
opérationnels 2,10 pour que nos stocks
se dire ceux du ministère de l'intérieur
puisse être mobilisée et je peux aussi
vous dire que nous avons intégré ses
besoins là dans nos travaux de
prospection pour l'avenir concernant les
sapeurs pompiers pour les forces de
l'ordre j'ai répondu au début de mon
propos
jean-noël barrot sur les marchés ça
rejoint la question de jean christophe
lagarde
la règle est simple c'est la fermeture
des marchés
et ensuite c'est si on considère qu'il
n'y a pas de solution de proximité
classique de supermarchés mais pas
seulement d'épicerie ou autres activités
à ce moment on peut décider de réouvrir
sur certaines communes le préfet peut
considérer que l'offre commerciale qui
existe sur la commune est largement
suffisante et qu'il n'est pas nécessaire
de rajouter un point de risques je jeudi
rajouter un point de ris parce qu'on
peut considérer que les supermarchés
sont aussi un point de risques et donc
de rajouter un point de risques mais
c'est d'avoir vraiment une approche au
cas par cas et elle est placée sous la
responsabilité des préfets et il ne
m'appartient pas même si je pourrai le
faire je ne souhaite pas le faire
expliquait au préfet que dans telle
commune la décision c'est celle ci ou
celle là je fais confiance au préfet ou
alors je les suspend pour apprécier au
mieux cette situation
puis vous ai posé une question qui est
compliqué c'est qu'elle est assez simple
à répondre en droit aujourd'hui pour les
jardins familiaux
les jardins familiaux ne sont pas
considérés comme un lieu de travail et
donc on ne peut pas considérer que le
fait de se rendre au jardin familial que
l'on a de cultiver et de faire pousser
une production qui sert généralement à
l'alimentation et quelquefois même en
secours
rentre dans ce cadre et pourtant
composant votre question et vous voyez
dans la gêne que j'ai sur ma réponse le
fait de me dire que c'est quand même
très embêtant parce que c'est une
culture j'ai été maire et j'en ai créé
c'est une culture c'est aussi aussi
quelquefois une urgence sociale et c'est
un vrai sujet donc je vais réouvrir la
discussion sur cela avec nos services
pour voir si on peut élaborer une sorte
de fait des fiches sur toute une série
de sujets une fiche qui permettrait
peut-être d'accepter que ça puisse être
réouvert compte tenu de la période dans
laquelle nous sommes
nous allons donner de la souplesse aussi
sur l'alimentation graines en plants de
tomates c'est la saison pour avoir un
peu de souplesse là dessus parce qu'on
sait que c'est aussi indispensable à la
question de l'alimentation dont je vais
ouvrir le sujet je ne réponds pas
précisément mais je crois que c'est une
vraie question sur asile et immigration
vous me posez la question du transfert
du bla ils sont déjà atteintes arrêté et
nous ne les mettons pas en oeuvre au
moment où je vous parle sur la question
de l'hébergement des plus démunis dans
les gymnases d'abord vous dire que ça
n'est pas la solution privilégiée
nous avons privilégié des solutions de
type sous l'autorité du lin de normandie
là je je parle en son nom parce que elle
est globale et des tailleurs piloter
même si une partie peut conseiller des
migrants est donc ce sera impactée au
budget du ministère de l'intérieur mais
peu importe on a privé j'ai des
solutions de type hôtel avec des coûts
d'objectif en tarif mais c'est pas la
solution privilégiée ailleurs quand on a
des situations tendues je pense à
aubervilliers a calé à grande synthe
dans les opérations de mise à l'abri que
nous avons conduite et que nous
continuons à conduire de façon père
l'aimait quasi quotidiennes par exemple
pour calais et grande synthe
nous recherchons là aussi
prioritairement des hébergements non
collectif et ce sont les orientations
que nous suivons du haut conseil de
santé publique
et lorsqu'il n'est pas possible de faire
autrement comme c'est le cas en
ile-de-france alors nous mobilisons des
gymnases parce que ça nous permet d'agir
dans des délais plus courts encore mais
je sais que ce n'est pas la solution
idéale et nous faisons en sorte que ces
gymnases respecte aussi un certain
nombre de recommandations qui sont
élaborées par l' agence régionale de la
santé pour limiter au maximum le risque
que nous connaissons madame d'une
termeer
je tiens à votre disposition madame le
député l'ensemble des moments de
consultations qui ont lieu avec
l'ensemble des partis politiques des
réunions courrier du 25 février 2020 du
premier ministre réunion le 27 février
présentation aux associations d'élus par
moi même et d'autres ministres le 5 mars
2020 et j'en ai rendu compte ensuite au
président de l'international et au
président du sénat courrier du premier
ministre aux maires de france
j'ai ensuite mis en place et
préconisations convenu avec notamment
l'association des maires de france mais
pas seulement par télégramme et un
certain nombre d'instructions sur la
constitution des bureaux de vote
l'organisation physique le matériel de
vote les consignes sanitaires générale
une réunion présidée par le premier
ministre a encore avec les chefs de
partis et groupements le 12 mars puis le
12 mars au soir le président la
république s'est exprimé sur le maintien
de l'élection et le lendemain j'ai
mises en oeuvre par visioconférence les
dispositifs dont je vous parle les
moments de discussion ont été nombreux
nous aurons l'occasion d'en reparler
mais ne laissons pas penser que c'est
une décision qui n'a pas été prise
conformément à ce que nous faisons
depuis le début c'est à dire prendre
l'avis des professionnels de santé et
ouvrir sur ce sujet les discussions les
plus larges possibles avec l'ensemble
des autorités quand elles sont
politiques en sont des présidents de
groupe à l'assemblée ou au sénat avec la
volonté de chercher la meilleure
solution peut venir la volonté du procès
politique c'est pas le sens de votre
remarque et nous l'assumons
mais c'est vraiment la méthode qui est
la nôtre et que nous allons maintenir
jusqu'au bout parce que notre
responsabilité c'est celle de garantir
la possibilité de la concorde nationale
dans le combat que nous devons mener
sans n'enlève rien aux questionnements
aux doutes aux critiques parfaitement
légitime mais c'est l'état d'esprit dans
lequel nous travaillons je je je reviens
sur ce que j'ai appelé hier devant le
sénat la guerre des masques pour dire
combien cela était insupportable et
votre question est parfaitement légitime
gelé repréciser ce qui s'est passé sur
l'aéroport de bâle mulhouse
moi j'ai connaissance d'un seul incident
elle vous en évoquer deux le gpal la
dimension du second mais ce qui s'est
passé dimanche après-midi un importateur
comme c'est le cas de beaucoup
d'importateurs appris beaucoup plus de
commandes que la capacité qu'ils avaient
en livrer et cet importateur là mais
comme d'autres et je le mets pas en
cause avait une commande de six millions
de masques de la rs grand test et on
sait l'urgence que l'on connaît sur ce
territoire
mais avait aussi d'autres commandes et
notamment la région bourgogne franche
comté et le conseil départemental des
bouches du rhône il devait livrer les 6
millions de masques le vendredi à la rs
il n'a livré que deux et ils avaient
annoncé qu'ils ont livré 4
supplémentaire le dimanche par un avion
qui se posaient à bâle mulhouse à
pour la de commandes de la rs grand test
au moment de l'arrivée il n'a été
constaté qu'il n'avait que 3 4 millions
de masques et effectivement la
préfecture a usé de son droit de tirage
prioritaire pour faire en sorte que la
totalité des masques soit mobilisée pour
la rs les hôpitaux les ehpad de la
région grand est
vous l'avez dit dans votre question il
n'y a pas de mise en cause de ce choix
là par contre la méthode a été mauvaise
et géré préciser cela tous les préfets
dès lundi soir ou mardi soir
expressément en disant que c'était une
méthode que je trouvais inopportune
parce qu'elle n'était pas conforme à
l'esprit dans lequel nous devons
travailler avec les collectivités
locales et que du coup il n'est pas
question qu'elle se reproduise
je pense que mon message a été clair je
vous le redis ici et je l'air et étirez
hier au sénat parce que on sait la
difficulté d'approvisionnement que nous
connaissons il y a un enjeu mondial sur
les masques le japon les états-unis sont
en carence de masquer ce ne sont pas les
seuls pays l'allemagne l'est aussi et on
sait les difficultés qu'on a en europe
et donc il est totalement inopportun que
des erreurs se produisent dans notre
relation l'état avec les collectivités
locales et mes consignes ont été sur ce
sujet clair jean christophe lagarde
j'ai abordé la question des marchés sur
la question de la classification de la
contravention ça relève du ministère de
la justice et donc je ne me prononcerai
pas sur les violences intrafamiliales
c'est un sujet de très grande
préoccupation parce que nous savons que
le confinement peut être le terreau des
violences intrafamiliales pense aux
violences sexuelles et sexistes je pense
aussi aux violences vis-à-vis des
enfants
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer devant
vous en question d'actualité
nous avons voulu faire en sorte que
l'empêchement de porter plainte
l'empêchement de téléphoner
l'empêchement d'alerté
n'empêche pas uno blij pas à subir et
donc on a développé tous les moyens
possibles dans tous les moyens possibles
il y a
ce qui n'existait pas c'est à dire que
évidemment il ya le 17
évidemment il ya le 39 19 que nous
connaissions mais nous avons développé
la capacité de communiquer avec la
police et gendarmerie par internet c'est
à dire de façon silencieuse si le
conjoint violent est présent et vous
empêche et j'ai rajouté la possibilité
de communiquer par sms en disant que
même si on n'avait pas accès peut-être
qu'on peut arriver à prendre le
téléphone et à pouvoir en allant aux
toilettes ou dans la salle de bains
envoyait un message de secours sur le
sms qui marche 24 heures sur 24 pour
répondre à votre question nous avons eu
environ 170 dossiers qui sont traités
par jour depuis que l'extension de
l'opérationnalité du 114 qui au départ
est fait pour les personnes
malentendantes
l'extension soit mise en oeuvre et une
vingtaine de dossiers de violences
conjugales sont quotidiennement orienté
depuis le 114 vers le 17 pour répondre
concrètement votre question je me fiche
de savoir s'il ya no pyj non pas dans un
commissariat mais je me fiche des ratios
pj s'il ya une alerte au pg ou pas au
fond ce la consigne est claire elle a
été donné en cela et donc qu'il y ait
plainte ou pas s'il ya une alerte on se
rend sur place et j'ai d'ailleurs
demandé en plus de cela que nous
prenions des initiatives par exemple que
nous développons les appels d'initiative
on sait qu'il ya un contentieux familial
mais il n'y a pas eu de plainte il ya
trois mois etc
on sait qu'il ya des tensions alors les
gendarmes ou les policiers un peu
spécialisés appellent et dans
l'entretien sentent s'il ya un problème
ou pas on a fait des interpellations
dans ce cadre là parce que dans ces
appels d'initiative on a senti qu'il y
avait un sujet on a fait une visite et
on a pu constater qu'il y avait des
problèmes et donc on est intervenue
immédiatement j'ai demandé au préfet de
ne négliger aucune possibilité de
relogement
sans même attendre l'instruction
judiciaire mais la garde des sceaux a dû
venir hier c'est de toute façon une des
priorités du ministère de la justice
mais si on a une famille qui a besoin
d'être accueillis on prend immédiatement
une place d'hôtel et on protège la
famille qui a besoin d'être accueillis
et évidemment on accompagne ensuite les
personnes dans la démarche
mais on n'attend pas c'est en ça que je
me fiche de savoir si on pouvait déposer
plainte ou pas mais je ne vis pas
évidemment tel ou tel commissariat on
n'attend pas la plainte
on intervient d'initiative et de façon
systématique et on a rajouté vous le
savez la mise en place de dispositif d'
alerte dans les pharmacies dans certains
centres commerciaux pour qu'on puisse
garantir cela malgré ces dispositifs
nous le verrons à la sortie du
confinement
nous avons actuellement un effondrement
des plaintes pour les violences
intrafamiliales
or nous savons tous que ça ne correspond
pas à la réalité et donc malgré ces
dispositifs large
on voit bien comment il y à des
violences qui nous échappent et comment
il ya des victimes qui nous échappent et
j'ai demandé sur ce sujet adrien tac et
marlène schiappa sur leurs secteurs de
compétence et la garde des sceaux en
appui de nos politiques
est-ce que ce sujet soit absolument
prioritaire et que nous ne lâchons rien
aujourd'hui les fiches opérationnels
sont mobilisés sont disponibles et nous
devons porter tous ensemble ce combat
l'attend
il est important et je vous remercie de
votre question merci monsieur le
ministre la parole est à monsieur
bertrand pancher pour l'europe liberté
était victoires pour deux minutes et
ensuite monsieur coquerel oui un
mouvement sioniste
monsieur lise quand allez-vous donner
des consignes de protection systématique
des forces de l'ordre en toutes
circonstances et clarifier les modalités
de contrôle
il ya un profond désarroi chez les
forces de l'ordre d'autant qu'ils ont pu
partir leurs stocks existants de masques
en début de crise le premier ministre
que j'ai interrogés par courrier le 6
avril dernier maféré compte les masses
porté par les agents dès lors qu'ils
estiment être en contact régulier avec
des personnes présentant des symptômes
de maladie et qu'il devait en cette
circonstance les invités à se couvrir le
nez la bouche voir porter un masque est
ce c'est quand même une doctrine qui
peut interroger
alors vous nous dites la situation
s'améliore à partir de quand pensez vous
être en capacité de donner des consignes
de protection des policiers et les
gendarmes en toutes circonstances ma
deuxième question de tunis pourquoi
continuez vous à vous acharner autant
sur les migrants cette période de crise
et quelle est la logique qui vous
action cette matière les centres de
rétention administrative continue à
fonctionner alors qu'il est impossible
envoyez quiconque à l'étranger ils sont
vecteurs de propagation de maladies
je vous cite le cas du cra de vincennes
on vient de tester aujourd'hui quelqu'un
qui avait une coronavirus et on a
relâché parallèlement son voisin de
chambre qui avait été hospitalisé il ya
quelques semaines auparavant
tout ça évidemment dramatique vous
n'avez pas suspendu les obligations de
pointer dans les préfectures pour les
personnes assignées à résidence vous ne
prenez pas les visas de court séjour
pour donner aux personnes concernées la
possibilité de bénéficier de soins
urgents et enfin évidemment je ne peux
pas ne pas évoquer la situation
catastrophique de mayotte où l'eau se
vend actuellement au marché noir
enfin je voulais vous remercier pour
votre précision concernant bâle-mulhouse
collègues insisté sur la nécessité
d'informer régulièrement les élus locaux
il ya encore des trous dans la raquette
et merci évidemment décortiquées
merci monsieur penchèrent la parole à
monsieur évident coquerel pour le groupe
de la france insoumise bonjour ministre
d'abord je voulais rendre hommage aux
policiers
malheureusement décédé gendarmes il
plaide la maladie à tous ceux qui sont
malades
testé on a parlé 2000 mais les policiers
les syndicats de police disent qu'en
réalité il ya dix fois plus depuis six
ont contaminé et réagir une première je
voulais pas vous en parler les
municipales et je vous réaffirme que à
partir du 12 mars c'est à dire à partir
du moment où le premier nice puis le
président de la république les soirs ont
fait état de l' aggravation de
l'épidémie et de son risque il n'y a pas
eu de consultation des chefs de partis
les chefs de groupe des différents
partir duquel une autre sur le maintien
ou pas des ministres
je voulais surtout parler de la
protection des policiers une fois de
plus vous avez parlé de doctrine
nationale
manifestement la pression c'est qu'elles
évoluent non pas en en termes de besoins
sanitaires mais plutôt en termes de
moyens suffisants et j'observe que vos
deux prix n'a évolué au début on disait
pas de masque après on a dit mettez des
masses qui a les symptômes alors je vous
ai entendu dire tout à l'heure que vous
n'étiez pas médecin mais excusez moi les
policiers sont pas médecins non plus
surtout que beaucoup de cas ce soir
automatique et enfin il ya des
conseillers administratifs sur lequel de
ne pas porter les masques lavables sur
lequel apparemment la médecine
préventive de la police s'est opposée je
voudrais donc avoir des questions vous
ai dit c'est vous avez huit cent dix
mille masques en stock
est ce que vous estimez aujourd'hui pas
de manière rétroactive que c'était
raisonnable d'avoir que huit cent dix
mille stocks de masques en stock qui
fait à peu près seulement trois jours
pour cent mille policiers sur le terrain
vous nous dites il y aura 14 millions de
commandes
où allez-vous les chercher parce que ces
14 millions pour l'instant on nous dit
qu'ils vont vers les hôpitaux les
hôpitaux et de 10 pour les voit pas
venir de l'état
j'aimerais que vous me disiez
concrètement où allez vous chercher les
14 puis s'il n'ya compris au maximum 40
millions de masques que vous comptez
atteindront ce que les policiers seront
intéressés de savoir où vous allez les
chercher
la dernière question juste réflexion je
pense que vous vous trompez fortement
sur la relative la durée des prêts quand
vous préfet l'allemand conclut du propos
la est mort pourquoi parce que
nous savons qu'en termes d'état
d'urgence sanitaire il y a évidemment
inévitablement des risques arbitral que
les consignes données sont extrêmement
importants stéphane peu à parler d'excès
en qualité avec le préfet du 93 je
confirme mais comme monsieur l'allemand
à deux reprises
merci j'ai des bleus je vais donner la
parole à monsieur alexandre android pour
le groupe de la république en marche
merci monsieur le président est beau
jour monsieur le ministre est déjà merci
beaucoup pour les éclaircissements que
vous nous apportez dans le cadre de
cette de cette audition et surtout
permettez moi de m'associer aux modeuses
de mes collègues sur le travail
remarquable et le dévouement avec lequel
nos forces de l'ordre accomplissent leur
devoir
aujourd'hui dans des conditions qui sont
on le sait très difficile monsieur le
ministre vous avez fait référence à
l'impérieuse nécessité d'une
coordination européenne approfondie pour
assurer l'efficacité des mesures prises
par les gouvernements et au regard des
réflexions portant sur le déconfinement
dans le débat public
est ce que vous pourriez nous donner
plus de détails sur les échanges que
vous avez prévu avec vos homologues
européens sur le sujet
est ce qu'il ya des échanges qui sont
prévues en format justice affaires
intérieures comment la coordination
entre administrations particules telles
la commission européenne la présidence
croate est même fait des propositions en
la matière et c est ce que vous pourriez
également nous éclairer sur la teneur de
vos échanges avec nos grands voisins
européens avec un regard particulier
pour les communautés où de forts enjeux
de transfrontalier existe vous avez
évoqué que les pratiques par exemple ne
relevait pas de vos compétences mais je
suis conscient que je sois beaucoup de
mercure par exemple sur du contrôle dans
des communautés où il ya une très grande
interaction transfrontalière il est
évident que la cité de dépendre d'une
coopération très efficace entre services
de voisins européens merci merci
monsieur wade la parole est à monsieur
pierre dharréville pour le groupe de la
gauche démocrate et républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je veux dire notre
préoccupation pour la santé des agents
des forces de l'ordre ordre est donné de
ne pas porter de me porter le masque que
si on détecte des signes donc chez la
personne contrôlée il semble même que
les hiérarchies direct les fasse retirer
même si elles proviennent d'une dotation
personnelle et privée
il est nécessaire de sortir dès que
possible d'une doctrine de pénurie et je
voudrais savoir si une démarche de
dépistage est envisagée dans les plus
brefs délais pour les agents je m'étonne
par ailleurs que des réquisitions été
opéré sans échange avec les
collectivités vous en avez parler
j'espère qu'il y aura une qu'il ya une
gestion centralisée de ses enjeux pour
les personnes étrangères soit il ya des
procédures judiciaires à activer soit il
paraît effectivement incompréhensible de
poursuivre les mesures de placement et
de maintien en rétention en absence de
perspective d'éloignement du territoire
l'état d'urgence enfin futile sanitaire
porte d atteinte à nos droits et
libertés fondamentales
il est indispensable pour garantir leur
nécessité leur proportionnalité que leur
cadre légal soit rigoureusement défini
et respectés et les interventions
maîtriser certains arrêtés municipaux
cité danger à son installation dans la
durée ce d'autant qu'il peut constituer
parfois un laboratoire pour le contrôle
des populations ou le voit par exemple
avec l'extension de l'usagé des drogues
dans quel cadre légal et réglementaire
avec kelly inscriptions de pouvoir plus
généralement donnée au préfet doit
permettre une application ajusté
démesuré c'est nécessaire par exemple
pour les marchés mais comment
entendez-vous veiller à une application
des mesures égale non discriminatoires
et sans expérimentation abusent ils
enfin question subsidiaire monsieur le
ministre
n'est-il pas nécessaire à vos yeux de
réévaluer le calendrier d'installation
des conseils municipaux élus au premier
tour voire compter sur eux dans ce
moment merci cher collègue monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole sur ses
quatre précédentes interventions
merci réponse à monsieur le député
plancher sur le plan cher sur les cra
les consignes ont été données pour
traiter les retenues qui serait malade
le conseil d'état a jugé qu'elle était
appropriée donc on peut considérer qu'il
faut ouvrir les cra souvent les
questions que j'ai eue aujourd'hui les
approches étaient différentes
quand il ya des gens qui sont en cra
dans le cadre de placements sortant de
prison ou qui ont fait l'objet de
trouble manifeste à l'ordre public
je ne serai pas décidé de façon
unilatérale de les remettre dans la rue
j'ai le souvenir d'un préfet qui a perdu
ses fonctions à lyon parce que quelqu'un
qui aurait dû être placées en cra ne l'a
pas été c'est rendu à marseille deux
jeunes filles sombre et donc ça engage
ma responsabilité personnelle mon boulot
c'est de faire appliquer la règle que
vous votez et pas de l'adapter en
fonction de critique qui peuvent être
faites et donc j'applique la loi et
j'applique les décisions du conseil
d'état
donc je pense qu'on peut les contester
mais je pense qu'il faut de la cohérence
sur ces sujets là il arrive que les
décisions du conseil d'état soit
contrainte soit des contraintes pour le
ministère de l'intérieur nous les
appliquons quand elle conforte nos
politiques nous les respectons et nous
les mettons en oeuvre sur les modalités
de pointage des étrangers les préfets
ont la possibilité d'aménager les
modalités de pointage des étrangers en
situation régulière qui sont à signaler
y danse évidemment ils le font c'est
cohérent période de confinement et c'est
important de pouvoir le faire
et sur la question des visas vous m'avez
indiqué que je ne voulais pas prolonger
les visas de court séjour c'est faux la
situation de l'expiration des visas fait
partie des cas où les préfectures
continuent de délivrer des titres et que
les instructions ont été données en ce
sens sous préfet de le 16 mars
et c'est important est de la même façon
pour les réfugiés et j'ai vu d'ailleurs
une tribune de parlementaires qui
faisait état du fait qu'il fallait
s'aligner sur le portugal
je vous invite juste à lire et à
vérifier ce que le portugal a fait et
avoir ce que nous avions fait avant le
portugal parce qu'effectivement pour
toutes les procédures liées aux droits
des étrangers quelle que soit leur
statut
à commencer par l'accès aux soins nous
avions anticipé cela et faire en sorte
que nous puissions offrir ses droits
avant que le portugal le fasse et donc
c'est vrai que j'ai lu avec intérêt la
tribune qui fait référence à des mesures
qui étaient déjà en vigueur en france et
un tout petit peu en avance sur le
portugal mais c'est une remarque qui
montrent que nous ne communiquons pas
assez sur les politiques que nous
mettons en oeuvre et qui prenne en
compte cette dimension humaine
absolument indispensable qu'il faut
mettre en oeuvre sur le d'écouté
coquerel vous
[Musique]
juste vous dire je reviens pas sur la
doctrine des masques j'applique une
doctrine nationale sur les masques n'est
pas discutée ministère par ministère
elle est discutée par les autorités
sanitaires et nous la mettons en avant
en fonction d'une doctrine la doctrine
est simple ça peut être lié à une
question de pénurie de masse parce que
personne ne conteste la pénurie mondiale
de masques aujourd'hui mais la doctrine
est simple les masques chirurgicaux et
de type ffp2 sont mobilisés en priorité
totale pour les personnels de santé
parce que sur ceux qui sont exposés aux
risques majeurs et donc vous
m'interrogez pour dire est il normal que
vous n'ayez que huit cent dix mille
masques non vous n'avez pas compris mon
propos mais je vais le reprendre mais
dans mon propos par exemple j'ai indiqué
que nous avions donné 1 million 400
mille masques qui était en notre
possession aux hôpitaux et nous avions
un stock supplémentaire les huit cent
dix mille masques que j'ai évoqués c'est
ce qu'ils ont été distribués à partir du
13 mars qui était aussi de nos propres
stocks pour accompagner la doctrine dont
on peut discuter qui peut être
contestées mais moi j'applique la
doctrine des autorités sanitaires de ce
pays pour mettre en place cette doctrine
ensuite on a rajouté le 26 mars trois
cent mille masques
j'ai indiqué depuis que 2 5 millions de
masques en provenance de chine
pour répondre à votre question ont été
réceptionnés et que les livraisons sont
en cours sur le territoire national j'ai
indiqué qu ainsi 3,6 millions de masques
avait été livré aux services du
ministère depuis le début de la crise et
j'ai précisé qu' au total avec les
commandes qui sont réalisés aujourd'hui
ce sont 40 millions de masques ont été
commandés par le ministère de
l'intérieur et c'est cela dont je vous
parle il n'y a aucune opposition aux
masques lavables s'il ya une instruction
locales qui étaient dans ce sens là
c'est une erreur d'interprétation
les masques non soignants parce que
masquer lavables on sait pas forcément
ce que ça veut dire mais parce que nous
soignons font aussi partie des solutions
que nous expérimentons et nous avons
procédé à des commandes aussi de masquer
non soignants en tissu et nous verrons
dans les semaines qui viennent les
adaptations qui seront faites sur ce
type de masque et la doctrine qui en
sera faite sur sur son usage c'est ce
que le professeur salomon a évoqué
vendredi dernier
pour le grand public en particulier et
donc c'est quelque chose que nous
étudions que nous testons et sur lequel
il faut ne rien négliger
sur cela je ne reviens pas sur votre
analyse des propos du préfet de
l'allemand je pense que j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer sur ce sujet le
député always a évoqué la nécessaire
coordination européenne approfondie
évidemment et elle a pu apparaître
insuffisante
c'est clair je pense qu'il y avait une
vraie volonté des institutions de la
commission européenne en particulier de
la commissaire et du vice président la
commission qui ont tenté cela mais que
les pays y compris avec des
organisations spécifiques comme
l'allemagne ou cdi active son initiative
des landes qui on prête été prise avant
même les initiatives de l'état fédéral
et du ministre or seehofer
voilà on a eu des initiatives qui n'ont
pas été coordonnés
il lutte était mieux qu'elle le soit
souhaitant que nous soyons capables de
gérer la sortie de crise le moment venu
dans ces conditions là sur eux
l'évocation du tracking et je pense que
seuls les ministres compétents pourront
évoquer ces questions dans l'enceinte
aux européennes mais c'est avec c'est un
sujet qui est posé aujourd'hui et sur la
gestion des transfrontaliers vous avez
raison il ya eu des diversités de
pratique on a tenté systématiquement et
j'ai eu à plusieurs reprises mais zain
mes homologues de faire en sorte qu'on
puisse avoir sur ces sujets des
solutions au cas par cas frontières paf
frontières en fonction des besoins pour
régler cela
vous savez comme moi qu'avec le royaume
ministre était un peu plus compliqué
c'est qu'il ya un moment donné où on a
expressément évoqué la possible de
fermer la frontière si le royaume uni ne
mettait en place
aucune mesure de confinement et que nous
avions même donné un ultimatum sur la
fermeture de ses frontières j'avais
échangé avec priti patel sur ces sujets
et ensuite pour une personne s'est
engagé les politiques ont été mises en
oeuvre de confinement au royaume uni
sous la responsabilité m'appartient pas
de juger de tout cela mais plus
globalement sur la diversité des
pratiques il faut absolument des
échanges se tiennent
un ou deux sommets j'aille dématérialisé
qui se tient par semaine et je crois que
la coordination sera vraiment nécessaire
au moment où on devra lever ce que je
souhaite le plus vite possible mais ça
je ne maîtrise pas les restrictions et
les contrôles aux frontières
pierre dharréville est revenu sur la
doctrine je n'y reviens pas sur la
réquisition que je m'en suis exprimé
j'ai regretté l'absence de communication
même si mais c'était pas le sens de sa
question non plus je ne regrette pas la
priorité qui était donnée au personnel
de santé de la région grand test on sait
combien ils sont engagés sur sur ce
sujet là vous avez évoqué l' usage des
drones usage des drones être très
encadré et c'est un outil aujourd'hui
que nous utilisons régulièrement pour
aider à la vigilance de nos forces de
sécurité mais on est vraiment dans ce
cadre là comme ont utilisé des
hélicoptères aussi qu'ils ont volé sur
la côte atlantique par exemple ce
week-end pour vérifier qu'on avait pas
de gens qui étaient sur la plage etc
mais mais voilà je pense qu'il faut pas
lier ça aux réflexions qui peuvent
exister ailleurs sur la question du
tracking est sûre cela sur les marchés
si j'ai bien compris toute la difficulté
d'avoir une règle légale c'est un peu ce
que je disais tout à l'heure c'est à la
fois la confiance territoriale que nous
devons faire pour le travailler avec les
élus locaux pour apprécier les
situations et accepter qui est du cas
par cas et la doctrine nationale qui est
plus égale sauf que si elle est
nationale par exemple les marchés sont
tous fermés en france et il a été décidé
commune par commune qu'on puisse le
faire évoluer et puis la dernière
remarque que vous avez faite sur
l'installation des conseils municipaux
je rappelle la loi et que nous avons que
vous avez voté il ya peu qui prévoit que
à partir du rapport que nous
présenterons parlement le 23 mai nous
déciderons de la mise en place rapide ou
pas des nouveaux conseils municipaux
l'ennui juridiques auxquels nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui est simple il est
que le ministère de la cohésion des
territoires apportée par ordonnance la
simplification du fonctionnement de nos
conseils municipaux un pci ou autres
collectivités et qu'on peut faire tout
cela de façon dématérialisée
sauf les élections personnels qui
doivent se faire à bulletin secret c'est
la loi et donc aujourd'hui nous ne
savons pas organisé à distance un vote à
bulletin secret avec toutes les
garanties liées au bulletin secret or
l'élection du maire et des adjoints
implique cela donc c'est ce point là qui
pose problème mais c'est le cadre
législatif dans lequel nous sommes et
nous ne pouvons pas y déroger et nous ne
disposons pas pour l'instant de moyens
d'organiser l'élection de façon
totalement dématérialisé qui permettrait
de garantir le vote à bulletin secret
pour le maire de la commune
c'est là dessus que nous h au pont parce
qu'effectivement on voit bien y compris
dans nos usages comme les choses
évoluent on voit bien qu'on peut
imaginer après l'installation formelle
du nouveau conseil municipal une
organisation démocratique interne avec
les oppositions qu'il puisse s'exprimer
évidemment de façon dématérialisée
mais nous avons cette impasse juridique
là et je ne sais pas la résoudre à
partir du 23 mai sur la base du rapport
soit nous avons les éléments de
perspectives sur la sortie du
déconfinement et on peut se caler sur ce
sujet soit ne les avons pas où les
nouvelles sont mauvaises et je n'annonce
rien en disant cela et à ce moment là on
pourra s'interroger peut-être pour
modifier ce texte le la je ne dis pas si
j'y suis favorable ou pas mais ça peut
être des choses possibles on a su y
compris pendant la période du
confinement sous l'autorité du président
de l'assemblée du sénat faire vivre la
démocratie parlementaire
comme nous le faisons à l'instant
présent merci monsieur le ministre
dernière série de questions la parole
est à monsieur jean pierre door pour le
groupe l'est républicain suivi ensuite
de monsieur maurice val au monsieur d'or
vous avez la parole oui merci monsieur
le président et merci monsieur le
ministre de cette matinée les
républicains vous le savez sont
solidaires avec tous les soignants avec
tous les acteurs de la sécurité civile
et avec nos citoyens qui sont touchés
dans leur chair dans un plan pandémie
j'avais fait un rapport en 2010 à
l'époque de la chaîne le confinement est
la meilleure barrière
la propagation du virus et à la démontré
toute son efficacité dans le monde
international et en dernièrement
d'ailleurs à roanne monsieur le ministre
dans notre pays
là près trois semaines et demie il y a
des premiers résultats intéressants mais
s'il y a également des trous dans la
raquette
il y à des zones qui confine ou d'autres
qui ne confirme pas du tout certains
quartiers certains départements il ya
aussi excusez moi du terme de nombreux
je m'en foutiste que l'on voit sur les
chaînes de télévision alors est-ce que
le mode des conventions des confidences
et confinement qui a été employés il ya
une semaine a probablement peut-être
d'été actor un signal de liberté qui a
été envoyé une population qui n'attend
que cela
monsieur le ministre pourquoi boiton
d'un côté les décisions préfectorales et
de l'autre des décisions et mer comme
les arrêtés d'interdiction ou de
dérogation est ce que c'est un choix
voulu de décentralisation delà de votre
part est-ce que l'unité de la nation
dans le domaine de confinement n'est pas
perturbé ou risque de l'être et enfin ma
dernière question succès c'est vous avez
détaillé la cellule interministérielle
qui est à beauvau pourquoi n'y at il pas
eu de délégué interministériel de
désigner comme cela avait été le cas
lors des dernières comité
interministériel de lutte contre la
grippe
il y a dix ans voilà c'était ma dernière
question de vous remercie merci monsieur
dehors la parole est à monsieur boris
vallot pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés monsieur le ministre beaucoup
de questions ont été posées pour des
trois questions nature très différente
et voudrait bien en excuser la première
dans le prolongement des réponses que
vous avez faite sur la doctrine des
contrôles concernent les infractions aux
règles du confinement
vous avez indiquée monsieur le ministre
que globalement vous n'aviez pas eu à
constater c'est heureux d'excès massif
de verbalisation mais vous avez aussi
reconnu des erreurs d'appréciation çà et
là je voudrais savoir sur ce que sont
les possibilités de contestation
réalisation le paiement d'une amende est
en droit la reconnaissance de
l'infraction est il demandé aux forces
de l'ordre de préciser aux personnes
qu'elles peuvent contester une pas payer
immédiatement l'amande
or dans la période actuelle la procédure
de recours qui se posent un courrier
recommandé dans un délai de 45 jours et
évidemment contrariés par les
dispositions que les bureaux de poste
eux mêmes ont été amenés à prendre la
question est la suivante quelle
procédure simplifiée adaptée de recours
le gouvernement entend offrir aux
françaises et aux français
la seconde question porte sur l'accueil
des étrangers et plus précisément sur la
situation des mineurs isolés qui sont ne
sont pas juridiquement tous des mineurs
protéger il nous est rapporté qu'un
certain nombre d'entre eux pour des
raisons diverses sont pas pris en charge
par ce qu'ils peuvent pas accéder
notamment à laquelle provisoire
d'urgence de certains conseils
départementaux
je voudrais que vous puissiez nous faire
un état des lieux certaines associations
qui nous avait déjà alerté lors de la
loi sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire
continue de le faire et de s'inquiéter
que certains enfants soient livrés à eux
mêmes or il est essentiel d'assurer leur
protection
la troisième question est une question
qui préoccupe les familles le préfet de
police de paris a procédé à la
réquisition des installations de rage
hills pour les transformer en or compte
tenu de l'importance de la surmortalité
consécutive à la pandémie et des limites
des capacités des structures funéraire
habituel et si personne ne disconvient
détention qui se font jour les
conditions faites aux familles choc
notamment ceux qu'ils auraient demandé
d'un point de vue financier de 150 euros
pour une semaine entière et puis 50
euros pour pouvoir passer une heure de
recueillement pouvez vous me dire ce
qu'il en est et nous confirmer si ces
informations étaient avérées que il
reviendrait à l'autorité de réquisition
d'en assumer le coût je vous remercie
merci monsieur van où la parole est à
madame sophie auconie pour le groupe udi
agir et indépendants qui ont adressé qui
ont adressé un courrier au premier
ministre le 20
en mars dernier et pour lequel
j'aimerais avoir votre un certain nombre
de réponses
ils demandent par exemple l'accès à un
dispositif de garde d'enfants de la même
manière que les personnels soignants il
s'agit ici pour eux de poursuivre dans
la durée leur travail au quotidien
ils ont demandé également un
renforcement de leurs capacités
d'autonomie opérationnelle notamment par
le basculement des appels téléphoniques
du 112 vers les centres de traitement de
la liste des 10 afin de désengorger le
samu ils ont demandé également de
pallier le risque de rupture
d'approvisionnement des masques
chirurgicaux et ternaires problèmes
notamment les ffp2 et de débloquer sans
délai des masques de la réserve
nationale à leur destination et enfin
ils ont demandé à ce qu'on autorise les
préfets à suspendre les règles relevant
de l'activité courante notamment qu'en
ce qui concerne les contrôles techniques
des véhicules
lesquels ne 2 ne doivent pas entraver la
mobilisation opérationnelle
monsieur le ministre quel sont vos
réponses par rapport à ses membres des
forces de nos quotidiens de notre
territoire et qui participe
effectivement à notre sécurité et la
sécurité de tous les français
merci chapelle avec la pole et tavannes
m me françoise dumas pour le groupe
la république en marche merci président
monsieur le ministre et la coordination
entre les acteurs de la défense et de la
sécurité est au coeur de l'organisation
de la lutte contre une copie 19 et je
tiens moi aussi à s'élever l'action des
préfets en général mais en particulier
celui du gard ainsi que leurs services
les opérations sont conduites dans une
logique de continue en sécurité défense
qui permet une approche globale dans le
cadre de la cellule interministérielle
de crise comme vous l'avez dit monsieur
le ministre je vais saluer d'en avoir
tout d'abord nos armées qui
interviennent aux côtés des forces de
sécurité intérieure et de sécurité
civile dans le cadre de l'opération
résilience en appui le soutien d
besoins locaux sur le front sanitaires
et sentinelles vous l'avez aussi dans le
cadre de la lutte contre je tiens à
rendre un hommage appuyé aussi aux
pompiers largement mobilisés et pour
passe localement à une augmentation
importante
l'intervention puisque beaucoup de
personnes sont confinées chez elles la
sécurité civile contribue également
grâce à ces moyens aériens à la lutte
contre la pandémie
ces hélicoptères les dragons réalise
aussi des transferts de passion de
patients vers des régions davantage
d'épargné tandis que les avions dash
participe à l'acheminement de matériel
militaire
un dragon à etel a également été
embarqué à bord du dixmude en direction
des antilles illustrant la bonne
coopération entre les divers
intervenants
si en tant que deux gardois du jeu peut
constater quotidiennement l'ampleur
l'activité de la base aérienne de la
sécurité civile pourriez vous nous
détailler la contribution globale de la
sécurité civile est la lutte contre
cette épidémie
je vous remercie merci madame la
présidente françoise dumas chemise une
question a rajouté avant de vous
permettre de répondre à l'ensemble
cela concerne des éléments qui nous
reviennent notamment du du pas de calais
sur le fait qu'un certain nombre de deux
migrants seraient certes mis à l'abri
dans un certain nombre d'hôtels mais que
caractère obligatoire de ce confinement
ne leur serait pas clair à l'esprit de
sorte que il ressortirait
quasi-automatiquement de l'endroit où
ils sont mis à l'abri et donc cela cela
inquiète localement la presse
quotidienne régionale sont faits chaque
jour l'écho évidemment cela suscite des
interrogations sur le fait
de bien expliquer que cette mise à
l'abri est assortie d'une obligation de
confinement pouvez vous sur ce point
également nous en dire plus vous avez la
parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président je vais
commencer par respect protocolaire pas
répondre à votre question
toute la difficulté est que ces mises à
l'abri sont faites sur des base de
volontariat c'est celle que nous avons
procédé à aubervilliers ou 732 migrants
dont 7 111 hommes isolés vivant dans un
campement illicite ont été mises à
l'abri et là en particulier ce sont deux
campements que nous sur lequel nous
intervenons celui de grande synthe et et
celui de calais sur lequel on proposait
on a éclaté sur l'ensemble de plusieurs
régions des relogements qui ne soit pas
dans des gymnases ça renvoie la
conversation que nous aurons tout à
l'heure mais ce ne sont pas des mesures
coercitives
ce ne sont pas des mesures de décisions
judiciaires avec déplacement obligatoire
donc la seule règle que nous avons c'est
celle de proposer la mise à l'abri
d'offrir la mise à l'abri et ensuite de
faire appliquer le confinement toute la
difficulté et on va se parler
franchement et si quelqu'un sort de lui
dire attention vous allez avoir un
procès verbal et une amende
et puis si vous récidivez je vais pas
revenir sur le montant et donc du coup
c'est vraiment aussi généralement on
s'appuie sur des associations mais qui
elles mêmes sont moins mobilisables
aujourd'hui qu'elles ne le sont
habituellement pour tenter de
sensibiliser d'accompagner les migrants
et leur faire prendre leurs
responsabilités je n'ai pas en tête les
éléments vous me rapportez peut-être que
je pourrais demander s'il ya des sites
en particulier les contrôles renforcés
de sécurité mais il faut savoir que la
seule législature dont je disposerai à
ce moment-là et celle dés lors que je ne
vais pas forcément placé ces migrants en
cra je comprends pas sur les
conversations que nous avons
précédemment
et puis il nous faudrait un acte
juridique pour cela c'est celle de les
menacer du procès verbal pour infraction
aux règles du confinement
ce qui n'est pas forcément la meilleure
façon de les dissuader
on apprenne de compréhension mais je
suis prêt à renforcer la présence
policière
s'il ya quelques sites en particulier
bien identifiés pour agir sur cela
je reviens et je prends l'exemple de la
verbalisation des sdf les réseaux
sociaux un moment donné ont flambé sur
ce sujet là donc évidemment on a
expliqué c'est un ordre du ministre de
l'intérieur y compris des associations
qui ont relayé ça j'ai demandé une
enquête précise on m'a interrogé des
associations qui ont relayé on ne
verbalise pas les sdf parce que ça n'a
pas de sens par contre on propose et
juin en normandie s'est fortement
engagée là dessus des caps et de
relogement hôtelier en particulier dont
je parlais tout à l'heure sur lequel
nous devons agir
ça me permet d'ailleurs d'évoquer aussi
la mise à l'abri des dna
là encore on est sur des dispositifs qui
sont délicats c'est la question de boris
vélo de façon systématique
on traite comme pour des sdf comme pour
des migrants l'urgence dans des
capacités de relogement hôtelière je
reviens pas sur ce que j'ai présenté
tout à l'heure parce qu'il est
nécessaire de pouvoir faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent être hébergé le plus
vite possible
on a des situations humaines sociales
sanitaires extrêmement douloureuse
extrêmement difficile et là aussi nous
est difficile de le faire respecter
nous travaillons évidemment en lien est
presque sous l'autorité concernant les
aime anna avec les services d e des
conseils départementaux et je précise
qu'ils ne sont pas nécessairement en
situation d'évaluer la minorité qui
doivent accueillir les mineurs qui se
présente et qui se déclarent mineurs
pour proposer des mises à l'abri et nous
avons aussi mis en place des souplesses
la répartition nationale qui avant nous
permettait de proposer que des amas n'a
identifié accompagné depuis tel
département soit dans l autre nous avons
suspendu les transferts de personnes
nous ne les faisons vraiment qu'au cas
par cas quand on sait qu'on a des offres
ou des capacités de logement
d'accompagnement qui sont de meilleure
qualité sur tel territoire mais nous ne
faisons pas de façon régulière et
automatique comme nous le faisions
précédemment
j insiste aussi sur le fait et je crois
que la garde des sceaux vouloir o dia
les juges courant fourons doivent
continuer à être accessible et je crois
que la garde vouloir à payer ça fait
partie des priorités qui sont les nôtres
pour agir sur ce sujet là je reste dans
la question de boris vallot
la morgue de rungis est géré par un
opérateur privé qui appliquent des
tarifs que j'ai découvert hier au moment
de la médiatisation et sur lequel je
demandais qu'un contrôle soit fait
précisément mais il faut vraiment être
que c'est un opérateur privé comme ce
sont des opérateurs privés qui gèrent ça
mais ce que j'ai vu hier
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
c'était aussi porté par un autre
opérateur privé qui d'annoncer les
tarifs d'un opérateur privé mais que
beaucoup de gens au site et le préfet
l'allemand alors qu'objectivement elle
n'y était pour rien mais quand on a
beaucoup parlé lui ce matin je me dis
que ça doit nous inviter à prudence mais
dans tous les cas j'ai demandé qu'on
fasse un point précis sur ces
tarifications et il me semble anormal
que les contraintes liées à la situation
de confinement et à des mortalités
massives soient imputés financièrement
aux familles donc c'est un sujet sur
lequel j'ai demandé dès hier soir quand
j'ai eu connaissance de sacchi un examen
précis qui soit fait et je vous ferai
passer au seul député les les éléments
sur sur cette question précise sur les
erreurs de verbalisation ou
d'appréciation mais aussi de
verbalisation elles sont toujours
possibles elles sont vraies sur tous les
sujets nous avons pris en compte cette
dimension là d'empêchement du recours à
45 jours et donc on l'a porté à 90 jours
le socle à 14 jours nous pensons que
nous serons sortir je n'annonce rien je
suis prudent mais nous serons sortis du
confinement et que du coup on sera en
mesure de contester cela je je je
n'invite pas à multiplier les
contestations mais je peux comprendre
qu'il y en ait parce que
l'interprétation d'une règle dans
24heures traduite sur le terrain sur des
grands principes
on a calé je vais tout vous dire on a
calé les attestations sur le modèle
italien
j'ai même fait traduire dans
l'après-midi le les attestations
italienne par une collaboratrice pour
voir si ça correspondait et après on a
développé on a fait expertiser sera
juridiquement donc on l'a fait vite dans
le contexte que nous connaissons et donc
du coup il ya pu y avoir des
imprécisions et des erreurs
d'appréciation et donc évidemment il est
normal que les recours existent et donc
ils sont élargies
90 jours pour que nous puissions faire
cela je reviens aux questions de
jean-pierre door je reviens pas sur le
soutien exprimé aux soignants au fsi et
aux citoyens mais ça je crois que nous
partageons tous et je reviens pas sur
son affirmation que je partage coûts de
confinement et la meilleure des
solutions
et il a évoqué des perspectives le
ministre l'île et vers en a parlé aussi
hier mais oui on observe du je cite je
m'en foutisme qui n'est pas massif je le
redis le la france fait partie des pays
qui ont respecté mais il ya des endroits
où on considère que c'est pas pour soi
il ya des endroits où on considère qu'on
est sans risque il ya des endroits on
pense qu'on est un super héros et donc
il ya des comportements totalement idiot
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut maintenir
les contrôles et que je les maintiens un
haut niveau mais en même temps je n'ai
pas abordé ça tout à l'heure dans
l'organisation de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure j'ai parlé du haut du spectre
avec des équipes a et b mais comme nous
avons intégré que nous serions soit un
combat long et difficile nous avons
veiller aussi à ce que l'organisation du
temps de travail des policiers des
gendarmes prennent en compte aussi cette
mobilisation de long terme
donc on ne peut pas être présent partout
même quand nous affirme chant cent mille
policiers et gendarmes sur le terrain
ils ne peuvent pas être auprès de 65
millions de français tout le temps donc
c'est d'abord un appel à la conscience
et à la responsabilité collective et si
besoin la sanction mais moi la consigne
que je donne aux forces de sécurité
c'est pas de faire des pv c'est de
protéger les français
et s'il faut faire des pv pour les
protéger nous devons assumer cela on a
parlé du déconfinement trop tôt mme avez
vous dit en même temps j'ai le souvenir
notamment de la question de damien abad
qui je le cite disait au premier
ministre tous les français s'interrogent
à la stratégie de sortie du confinement
qu'entendez vous par le déconfinement
doit-il être progressif sera-t-il
organisé par région ou par classe d'âge
donc le premier sera effectivement
répondu aux questions qui lui étaient
posées
tout comme le premier ministre et ça me
permet de répondre à la question de
sophie auconie répondra aux questions et
aux lettres qui lui sont adressés le
ministère de l'intérieur donnait des
éléments à son cabinet pour préparer la
réponse mais je laisse au premier
ministre le soin de répondre au courrier
qui lui sont adressés et je ne peux pas
évoquer sa réponse maintenant parce que
je ne la connais pas mais je sais que il
a des éléments et qu'il ne tardera pas à
répondre sur ce sujet françoise dumas
pour terminer mes réponses j'espère
n'avoir rien oublié vous préciser qu'il
ya eu depuis le début de la gestion de
crise 47 mille interventions de pompiers
que des moyens aériens sont mobilisés
aussi vous avez évoqué les moyens qu'on
a embarqué à bord du dixmude
je vous avoue que si les missions
d'appui du centre de crise auprès de la
cicta civile à la réunion mayotte aux
antilles et où précisé que depuis le 25
février devant procéder à 173 évacuation
sanitaire par exemple au titre de la
sécurité civile mais nous sommes aussi
mobilisés sous l'autorité d'ali thirion
qui est doublement engagés à la fois
dans la cic est à la fois dans ses
fonctions de directeur général de la cie
que des civils aient les gestions de
crise dans le soutien au smur au centre
de réception des appels dans de nombreux
départements
et une chose est sûre ces classiques des
civils dans son acception la plus large
militaires sapeurs pompiers
professionnels sapeur pompier volontaire
est un niveau d'engagement exceptionnel
qui fait honneur à leurs engagements
merci monsieur le ministre pour
l'ensemble des réponses que vous avez
bien voulu donner aux questions qui vous
ont été posées par les collègues
je veux donc vous remercier je rappelle
à nos collègues que la semaine prochaine
nous nous retrouverons mercredi 15 avril
pour l'audition des ministres bruno le
maire et gérald darmanin à 17h30
et si leur disponibilité est confirmée
nous nous retrouverons également jeudi
16 avril à 10h30 pour entendre le
professeur delfraissy président du
comité des scientifiques et madame
geneviève shen directrice générale de
santé publique france